for more information visit their website
at bookcritics.org
in 1968 historian martin gilbert became
the official biographer of winston
churchill
knighted in 1995
sir martin has written and edited over
70 books on topics including world war
one
world war ii
the history of the 20th century the
holocaust
and jewish history
for the next three hours martin gilbert
will be taking your phone calls and
emails
as our guest on book tv's in depth
[Music]
sir martin gilbert what's the relevancy
of winston churchill today
he was a wise man he had foresight and
he believed that humanity could better
itself
and what about the the timing in which
we're in in the beginning of the 21st
century
well he
i don't think he really was a victorian
or a
20th century person he his ideas spanned
all centuries i was very excited to find
once when i was listening by chance in
my car radio to john major in 1993
talking about the needs of education
being free from class
and i thought wait a minute i remember
churchill saying that from my researches
in his very first political speech
in bath in 1895
well it's an interesting question
because american politicians also spend
a lot of time quoting winston churchill
maybe more today than before why do you
think that is well first of all he he
did have a gift of of phrase he knew how
to express things very clearly he had
humor i think that also comes across
and what he said was was universal he
had a sense that human beings could
grapple with their own destiny that they
didn't have to be the victims of forces
moving
catastrophically about that wars could
be avoided by foresight and that when
wars came they could be fought with
determination as we're talking which is
early february of 2003 the united states
and britain are in very close ties and
looking at the possibility of going to a
war in iraq how do you see this as
compared to the challenges that winston
churchill was facing
every war is a challenge churchill
always made the point that it's easy to
get into a war
and it may be morally right to get into
a war
but once war begins you can't predict
how it'll emerge
you can't minimize the suffering that
war can cause he had a horror of the
actual suffering of war that's why at
the time of the normandy landings in
june 1944
he he hesitated he he agreed to do it
but he was very frightened and an
american came to see him and said
the president's worried that you're
frightened of casualties and he said
it's not casualties i'm frightened of
it's the number of casualties
and is that a message for george bush
today and tony blair
well i think look both men know exactly
what they're doing
both men have all the facts at their
disposal and i'm sure neither of them
underestimates what war
can do on the ground but if a war has to
be fought and that is their judgment
then of course casualties are part of it
i want to go to you one of your books
the history of the 20th century which i
must tell our viewers as you sat down to
do this interview you looked at this
book and said i've never seen this i've
never seen that edition before audition
it looks very handsome
it is new out in paperback a concise
edition of the acclaimed world history
history of the 20th century when did you
write this and you've kind of said i can
take a copy away yes you may yes you may
i started writing it i collected the
material for many years but i started
the actual physical writing in 1995
and it's the three volumes came out
annually
in
98 99 and 2000 and then the the final
reduction the single volume which took a
year and a half to do to reduce it
i was able to really fine-tune some of
the themes and
make make it a genuine history of the
whole 20th century it doesn't only focus
on world war ii or on the modern era it
tries to bring in from the very
beginning
the
the human struggles the human stories of
the century
you also write in here and i and i
presume this is around the 1990 1991
period
about george first president george bush
you say he also pondered a historical
president precedent as he later recalled
in the first weeks of the crisis meaning
the persian gulf crisis i happen to be
reading a book on world war ii by the
british historian martin gilbert i saw a
direct analogy between what was
occurring in kuwait and what the nazis
had done especially in poland yes i was
astounded when when i read that it
appears in the book which he did with
brent scowcroft
and in fact during that period when the
question was should
er saddam's invasion of kuwait be
considered a cause of war i kept getting
telephone calls from american
journalists asking me questions about
churchill and the war and i said why are
you asking me this and apparently on air
force one the president had mentioned my
book but he hadn't said which book
they'd assumed it was the
churchillography and he'd said that you
know i've been reading this book and and
what it really told was that from the
very first days of hitler's invasion of
poland there had been terrible
atrocities against polish civilians
against clergymen against jews against
leaders in every polish village and he
was worried that if saddam was doing
that in kuwait one might only learn
about it in many years time
and meanwhile it would be too late many
people maybe
know about your books about churchill
but may not be as familiar with some of
your earlier books about the holocaust
and world war ii here are two of them
auschwitz and the allies and the
holocaust when was auschwitz and the
allies published it was published in
1981 it i i started work on it about 10
years earlier in the very early 70s and
it really focuses around this
controversial question of why the allies
didn't bomb auschwitz and i started it
began as being a 20-minute answer in a
short sort of colloquium in an academic
conference and then it became a
three-hour talk rather like our chat now
and then i thought you know this really
ought to be a book because although it's
a tiny episode you know the the story
only lasts a few weeks
in world war ii nevertheless it it's an
important one and what was what what
caused it to balloon
i think what caused it to balloon was
that many survivors of the holocaust
particularly those who'd been in
auschwitz and had seen allied aircraft
flying overhead there had been many uh
daylight bombing missions by american
bomber forces flying very high of course
uh striking targets in the vicinity and
so they
they began in the 1970s and even
increasingly now to say well why didn't
the allies britain and america churchill
and roosevelt do something and so i set
about trying to answer it and did you
find as to whether america was remiss
well it's a complicated story like all
history and one of the reasons why my
books are so fat is i try not to give
simple answers or glide over
complexities
basically when the allies were asked to
bomb auschwitz
uh churchill's immediate reaction was do
it get anything out of the air force you
can he he wrote to the foreign secretary
and invoke me if necessary and the
american
air force general in britain who was
consulted general eco was also very keen
to do it but it was just after the
normandy landings
and uh
at that point all the targeting really
focused on the needs of normandy and in
fact eisenhower was for that crucial
window of opportunity when auschwitz
could have been bombed eisenhower's in
charge of the targets and the under
secret war in washington john j mccloy
said kill it this request we just can't
deal with and it was very unfortunate
that he used that language because it
sounds as if he was being cynical but of
course at that time he was focusing
on the the need to sort of destroy all
the german facilities around the
normandy beachhead to stop the allied
armies being really crushed by the
germans moving forward and then once the
that window opportunity had passed
then the demands for the bombing were
replaced by demands for protective
documents for the jews then in hungary
the last large group of jews alive and
there both roosevelt and churchill
responded immediately and indeed
dispatched raul wallenberg the famous
swedish diplomat
who together with the other diplomats in
budapest issued these protective
documents so from a sort of bad story
and a bad moment you have
a great deal of life-saving activity by
the allies 1985 this book the holocaust
yes
was that your first um major it was my
it was my first and in a way my last
major work on the subject it's still in
print
and uh it's it's still widely used i i i
worked on it for 15 years 15 years right
i started collecting material in 1959 on
my first visit to poland which was 25
years before it was published
and
i put everything in it that i could of
material i discovered and my main aim in
this book was to tell the personal
stories
the voices of those who had actually
been through it
from memoirs from interviewing survivors
from finding diaries written at the time
in the ghettos and in the camps so it
was an attempt to put into the holocaust
writing equation
the voices of those who are the victims
well then we that brings us to two of
your books which are a little bit newer
that i want to show our viewers that
have something to do with those specific
people first of all i think the earlier
one is this one the boys what is that
well the boys were a group of
men and women in their 60s and 70s who
approached me
about 15 years ago and said please tell
our story and they were polish and
hungarian jews youngsters who were 10 12
13 years old when the war began
and they went through everything through
all the camps for all the terrors
and they were liberated in czech
slovakia and flown to britain and there
they were rehabilitated there they were
really brought back into normal life and
from britain they went all over the
world many are here in the united states
in canada in south america and israel in
south africa and australia and they
asked me to tell their story and it was
a wonderful opportunity for me because i
have there were 732 of them and i have
several hundred voices there each
talking about different stages of their
lives their youth
in pre-war europe in is it were the
happier times their struggles during the
war and then most inspiring in a way to
write about their rehabilitation after
the war in strange lands new languages
new customs and how they really rebuilt
their shattered lives any idea how many
of them are still alive
yes of the 732
more than 550 are still alive they were
they were all 16 17 18 when the war
began
and they were scooped up by large royal
air force lancaster bombers and flown to
the north of england and how does that
this book the boys compare with the book
that's just coming out the righteous
that's my most recent balkan in a way it
was both the most difficult to write
and for me the most inspiring because
it's entirely about good people
who risk their lives and the lives of
their families
to hide and save jews all over europe
and it's the story of
we know about 20 000 of these people
there must have been many more who were
murdered during the war by the nazis
murdered because they were hiding jews
and those who were hiding with them were
also murdered but this is the story of
people all over europe
who
made tremendous efforts to hide jews in
their cellars in their attics in barns
sometimes in caves and holes
and saved innumerable lives the photo on
your cover includes doctor excuse me
father bruno father who is he father
bruno is a belgian priest a remarkable
man who despite the tremendous nazi
pressure against everybody certainly
against helping jews for being deported
and murdered father bruno undertook to
take
jewish boys jewish youngsters
and find homes for them in belgium
families who are prepared to take that
tremendous risk
and he was fearless
he was
at one point
very much under the frown of the gestapo
but he went on nevertheless to the very
last day of the war rescuing youngsters
here's six jewish girls you have a
picture of in this book you say who
lived as christians that's right now
many of these rescuers about whom i
write
there was no way they could hide a
jewish person in their home
without suspicion and the germans were
very clever
the gestapo was very clever in
persuading neighbors to betray if it was
known you were hiding a jewish person
all sorts of inducements
bread salt brandy flour these things
desperate in short supply if you'll just
point your finger at a jew in hiding and
then of course that jew would be taken
and killed the person hiding them would
be killed
and what many families did they said
right we'll take you in and we'll
pretend you're a cousin from the country
you're
a neighbor's uh a neighbor who's been
killed in the war's child
but you'll have to be a christian you'll
have to behave like a christian you'll
have to come to church you'll have to go
to mass
and uh and this way these people are
saved and i know many of them who to
this day even regard
the church as their savior although
they've gone back to being jewish and
married jewish become
you know active in jewish communities
but still those five years when they
were
masquerading as christians within a
christian family meant a great deal to
them more than just their lives being
saved they had a sense of the christian
church being their savior sir martin
gilbert is our guest this month on
in-depth if you don't know anything
about in-depth let me tell you it's
about a year and a half old it's a
program that we do the first sunday of
every month it's three hours with an
author to discuss his complete body of
work and with sir martin gilbert it is a
long body of work almost 70 books you
can go to our website if you would like
a list of all of them
and the website is www.booktv.org
but if you would like to join us today
we're going to start taking your phone
calls in about 10 minutes here's how you
can join us if you live in east or
central time zone 202 585-3880
if you live in the mountain or pacific
time zone 202 202-585-3881
we would also invite any email uh
questions that you might have today and
you're very welcome to do that the email
address is journal excuse me is book tv
at cspan.org again that's book tv at
cspan.org let me find out a little bit
about you when did you become the
official biographer of winston churchill
first of all
what does that mean
in 1962 i joined churchill's son
randolph
and i worked with a small team of other
researchers i began as the junior
researcher
working on preparing the biography of
his father and indeed writing the first
two volumes
and
then randolph died in 1968 and i was
asked to
take on his work carry on the work
and so i completed six more volumes of
the narrative the story and also 15
volumes of the churchill papers and i'm
still working on those i've still got
five of those to complete the last one
which was published by norton
uh in new york two years ago was 1941.
everything that he wrote everything that
he received in 1941 and how many volumes
are there going to be total 15 are down
five more together
and of the of the bio biographical
portion which this is the compilation
that's the combination there are eight
biographical volumes two of which rando
churchill did up to 1914
and then the rest which i did up to his
death and this is the compilation of all
of us and that i then put everything
together and rewrote randall's first two
volumes so it would be a
a comprehensive work and for those
viewers who are interested this book
came out in 1991. now randolph churchill
considered the problem child
well curiously he was very close to his
father he his main problem was that
during the second world war he was very
badly injured in the western desert
behind german lines
and damaged his spine and always had
pain
and he found drink was a way to assuage
the pain unfortunately drink got the
better of him but then he uh despite
this injury he parachuted into german
occupied europe
he was behind nazi lines in yugoslavia
and there again he was he was hurt
and he was very brave and his father
loved him dearly and he loved his father
but unfortunately drink could sometimes
get the better of him he died at age 57
57 i often saw him fighting against it
and he would make great efforts and he
was also like his father
so witty and so humorous and so
determined i think to to get the history
right
he he and i used to have great battles
over really
minuscule points of history and even i
would sometimes say but you know why do
we have to
deal with this in such detail and he'd
say we have to get it right
and and he was right i mean there is
such a thing as true history but it
takes a lot of work to get it here is a
picture of him in one of your books do
you know remember how old he was in this
photo oh i guess it says 1965.
so that's in his study in his study yes
i can't quite see it that's the picture
of randolph taken by me uh is he on the
telephone yes he is on your television
does he have a little cigarette yes he
does have a cigarette dangling here
that's definitely right and that would
have been the year that his father died
right because his father died and when
he took over actually very
bravely and strongly the
responsibilities of being head of the
family looking after his mother feeling
responsible for
you know the family heritage really and
the american connection one of the
american connections to all of this was
the uh one of his marriages correct
well no his his his great friend whom i
knew well and who he was in touch with
all his life
was k halle who lived here in washington
dc
and she was a real character
and towards the end of his life randall
was asked by robert kennedy and
jacqueline kennedy to write the official
biography of jf kennedy
and we flew to washington and kay haley
put us up on the top two floors her
wonderful house 3001 dead place
northwest
and he had met her wanted to marry her
in the very early 1930s
and somehow their friendship was
preserved and it was k halley who fought
like a tigress
to get winston churchill his honorary
citizenship of the united states and i
think the proudest moment of
of randall's life of my randall's life i
can call him that was when he came over
here to washington and with kay haley
received from president kennedy the
honorary citizenship of the united
states for his father
pamela churchill harriman she's very
british how does she fit into this she
ended up american and a very
distinguished american and u.s
ambassador to
paris uh pamela was randall's first wife
and the mother of his son who was also
called winston
and pamela haram was very important for
me
because
she always had time of day i made her
own very busy schedule as an active
democrat here in washington
to talk about the
hundreds of hours which she spent with
winston churchill during world war ii
often when there was a very bad night
perhaps on the eve of an invasion for
example the invasion the allied invasion
of sicily
and church was very nervous what would
the casualties be
would the invasion succeed
and he needed someone to sit with him
and talk to him someone who would
understand the burden on him and someone
who would be able to
calm him and talk to him about the
situation and pamela harriman was the
one who who really played that role she
she was an essential feature
in those crucial moments
we're going to take some of your phone
calls and then go back and take us
look at more of these books we have your
atlas series we have the two books of
the first and second world war we'll get
to all of that first is lincolndale new
york hello good morning excuse me good
afternoon
uh
i'd like to ask
an objective historian without the ties
to any american political uh party uh to
get your
comments on the apparent ineffectiveness
of american democratic party politicians
of jewish origin
uh during
the
time encompassed by the holocaust
their complete lack of
effectiveness in bringing this issue to
roosevelt's attention and come and you
know we had three
jewish
democratic committee chairman at that
time house uh foreign affairs committee
chairman saul bloom sen house judiciary
committee chairman emmanuel seller and
rules committee chairman adolph sabbath
none of them
seem to have had any effect
on this and i'd like your views on that
thank you very much and a good interview
it's a very important question i think
that in the main the american jewish
community like incidentally the british
jewish community with regard to
churchill in england
felt
very nervous about pushing
any jewish related issue they wanted to
keep a low profile they of course wanted
the allies to win the war they
understood that that victory over hitler
was essential but they were inhibited by
not wanting to create a high jewish
profile and there were one or two in
fact there were one two people here in
washington who did try to raise uh the
alarm
and in the main they were told by the
jewish leadership don't do it don't
create waves we simply have to support
the war effort so it's a sad period in
american jewish history and also in
british jewish history but there were
voices everyone has to give them credit
as well of people who did speak out and
people who tried to push for a higher
profile and and above all for a higher
public awareness of what was happening
and there was a moment when it's quite
interesting in my churchill work
uh i i deal with it when
churchill wanted to
publish a statement in december 1942
after the courier yankowski had been to
see him and roosevelt with news of the
plight of the jews in poland
churchill wanted to issue a statement
saying that the jews were being murdered
this was not just spasmodic this was
deliberate systematic these were bestial
crimes and that they would be punished
after the war and there was considerable
pressure on churchill uh not to make it
so emphatic by the jewish community in
britain they felt you know many other
people were suffering in europe and so
on that it would be invidious to select
them out but churchill persevered he
felt that the holocaust was something
over and above the normal nazi
persecutions as indeed it was and he
persuaded roosevelt and roosevelt joined
in this declaration of the 17th of
december 1942 which was an astounding
and powerful
appeal to the world and to the germans
to say that these things were happening
and were evil
next call irvine california
good afternoon yes can you hear me yes
uh good afternoon stuart gilbert my
question is this uh during the 20th
century the two regimes that persecuted
jews the most were the national
socialists and the union of soviet
socialist republics not
wonder if available they're not
connecting the dots
well i i think the the the answer to
that question is really that there's no
such thing as jews in quote marks
there's no jewish type there's no jewish
stereotype much as hitler and stalin
from their very different perspectives
tried to create one and in fact if you
look for example at uh
margaret thatcher's england and the
tremendous revolution which she brought
about in my country certainly jews were
very prominent there in the capitalistic
and free enterprise
uh economy which she created and not
only economy but um really mindset that
she created and i think you will find
jews who don't incidentally have to have
any political uh affiliations or views
necessarily but i think you'll find
there on both sides of the divide
jews played an appalling part an
atrocious part in in my view and in my
books
as supporters say of the soviet regime
which you mentioned often at the at the
center of the terror
uh perpetrating instruments of of that
regime also in in eastern europe jews
played a prominent part in imposing
communism and maintaining communism in
countries like poland and hungary and
romania but at the same time jews were
among the the dissidents the opponents
the people who spent long years in the
gulag like natan sharansky and and jews
were among those who suffered from
tyranny so i think the answer really is
there's no such thing as a jew and well
it would be nice if you're a democratic
jew to feel that all jews are democrat
or if you're a republican jew to feel
all jews are republican the truth is
jews cover
like americans or britain's every
spectrum bridgewater massachusetts uh
hello mr gilbert um first of all i just
want to say i admire all of your work
very much i think you're a very fine
historian thank you um but i have a
question about the official biography um
you know i i've read it i admired very
much and i'm always struck by how
comprehensive and how complete it is and
so i have really two questions for you
and
this is part of i'm struck after reading
lord jenkins recent biography of
churchill um if you look at his
footnotes he cites the official
biography
more than any other source right and so
i'm wondering do you think
you know the continuing flood of
churchill biographies are necessary
because of the comprehensiveness of your
work
and if so where do you think uh
churchill scholarship needs to go from
here we should show our viewers so they
can get a feel for the the breadth of
this this is the paperback edition of
the reducing the reduced
the paperback edition of the reduced
portion no no i'm interested in what you
said first of all of course there's no
such thing as as any form of exclusivity
for any historian and although i was
called the official biographer i had no
uh privileged access the papers on which
i worked i made available to any
historians who were working on aspects
of churchill's life or british or world
national life
and
similarly the archives which form the
basis of my work are also open to
everybody i had no privileged access to
archives that were otherwise closed
because the biography is so big because
there are these 15 document volumes and
the eight volumes of the biography
i think it's inevitable that all
biographers are going to to mine it uh i
have nothing against that i mean the
what i've against is when people do it
and don't acknowledge it and and lord
jenkins was very generous in his
acknowledgements uh it's inevitable if
someone has been producing material
for 45 years and then you know it's
going to become the the basic
mind the basic uh
coal mine there are areas i think in
churchill's life which i would like to
see further explored
and and i always you know when
historians approach me i always try to
uh to encourage them i think that i mean
there was a very important book written
by no relation of mine a professor
called bentley beagle but i think was at
chicago university on churchill's social
reforms before the first world war i've
written about it but that area i think
would have a great deal more down
particularly as churchill unlike many
contemporary politicians
the legislation he promoted such as
national insurance and vast improvements
for for workers in factories and in
shops
he tended to draft it all by hand
and to labor over it himself and so i
think somebody could study that to good
effect and there are other things are
aspects of the second world war
which i think you know there are so many
ways of looking at the second world war
and i think if you take something like
churchill's relations with the soviet
union which you know i myself would like
to to write about it then there's a
subject which brings together my own
interests churchill and the jews and i'm
hoping to produce a book on that topic
but there are many many topics and uh
you know it's nice to feel that the
official biography
is is is providing historians as well as
readers with
a vast resource does the official does
the word official biography mean
anything in terms of the approving of
the content
by the family or someone now the most
remarkable thing at no stage i started
my work full time on the biography when
randolph died in 1968 and i'm still
working on it and at no time has any
member of the family asked to see my
work
before it was published any politics
british politicians anybody well they
like to see it for other reasons but not
not a census
but
the family have really been remarkable
they they they understand that i have
access to a lot of material that's
personal that's sensitive that deals
with his family life that deals with his
private life that deals with perhaps
very stormy relationships and very
controversial relationships but they
never asked to
to see it at all
and uh
and that that really means that it's not
an official biographing sense that it's
sort of a a commission biography where
the author makes sure his
where the subject makes sure his point
of view or the family of the subject
make sure the point of view of the
subject is dominant i had a free free
range do you have any special monetary
recompenses for for this that are not
normal for um
like the royalties from the book or
something no i get new royalties the the
royal royalties from this book the
royalties for the church biography all
went to the church or family um but i
got a salary and i've worked really
basically through grants through
applying including to some american
grants it's been a struggle actually
that's why in one way it took so long
from 1968 to today and i've still got
five volumes of his papers to publish
and i'm actually now looking for funding
where are you where have you taught in
the united states
my very first visiting professorship was
in 1965
in the university of south carolina
columbia south carolina
and i have very amazing memories of that
because it was at the very height
of president lyndon johnson's uh
remarkable civil rights legislation and
my class were totally against against
what johnson was doing
and was among
tens of thousands of students from the
southern universities who were bounced
together with me to atlanta to hear
johnson introduce
in a vast stadium to introduce his
legislation and i've never seen
such a master of politics confronted by
these kids many of whom regarded him as
a traitor to the south
and partly by playing on the patriotic
vietnamese
line because he knew each of the men in
my class wanted to go to vietnam and
fight but partly by playing on their
patriotism he somehow had them in the
end eating out of his hand so that was
an interesting lesson for me and one i
was able i hope to convey in my history
of 20th century
lyndon johnson's great political skills
and achievements
and then i came back
to
california some four months ago
as a visiting professor at the
university of california san diego and
that was delightful not only for the
palm trees and the ocean and the amazing
climate and there i taught a holocaust
course but my main american link now is
i'm a distinguished fellow what they
call a distinguished fellow at hillsdale
college michigan
which is a wonderful small college
roughly halfway between detroit and
chicago and i'm going to go there every
year and teach there i've already done
one stint and that's very exciting for
me it's a small college the students are
keen the president of the college larry
arn is somebody who has a real vision
for his college so that's my that will
be my future
american link do you find that the
students that are teaching today in
hillsdale are different from the
students that you taught in south
carolina goodness me they are different
i mean they're partly they're different
because and this is the curious thing to
say but as i'm teaching history since
1965 there's been a lot more history and
curious enough i think the perspectives
in 1965
looking back with hindsight were very
limited
the world somehow
had defeated evil hitler had been
defeated mussolini hirohito they'd all
been defeated and we had a few domestic
problems still to deal with but it was
almost as if
real history dynamic history troublesome
history had come to an end and
and today my students at hillsdale you
know they are really plunged into a lot
of troublesome history i mean even from
the
narrow american perspective if i can
call it narrow i'm not being cynical you
know what is america's place in the
world can america
be the policeman of the world does there
have to be as indeed there may have to
be some form of new imperialism where
you know some
some distances some democracies some
patterns of liberal behavior will have
to be maintained from outside and you
know these are big questions for for
kids to have to answer because it's
going to be in their adult lifetime that
the united states will resolve this las
vegas go ahead
las vegas you're on the air
las vegas go ahead i'd like to ask mr
gilbert
professor gilbert question regarding
any general views he has as to
flaws in public policy such as
has been retrospectively
uh describe with regard to the vietnam
war but uh i i particularly want to ask
him specifically about the post-world
war one period
whether he feels that
major mistakes were made by the allies
with regard to the peace
process
and whether
anything
differently could have been done that
might have prevented the rise of
nazism and fascism
in europe
well that's a tremendously important
question it's one i've tried to address
both in my history of the first war and
my history of the second world war
and in my 20th century histories
i think the answer to your question is
is is yes there were things that could
have been done differently
from the european perspective i see the
withdrawal of the united states
from europe and its
refusal to participate in the post-war
settlement
as
as bad as having given in a way the
um
the undemocratic powers a greater edge
in europe
i also see britain's failure and
france's failure to achieve a much more
balanced peace which which many people
wanted churchill for example regarded
the treaty of versailles as grossly
harsh
so that was definitely a failure of the
european victors uh their sort of uh
almost vengeance-like approach to the
peace and forcing the germans and the
other defeated countries uh such as
hungary into a position of of uh really
uh
wanting to have their own revenge so i
think those two things could have
changed and also then i thought
there was a move for a united europe
there was uh there was a
a group of people who believed that
there should be a coming together
of the
former victors and the former defeated
churchill himself proposed a system
whereby france and germany would come
together in an alliance guaranteed by
other states
but it was too soon this this idea of a
united europe which we have now and
which we see its strength many people in
europe see the strength of the european
union as being exactly that that it will
not replicate the mistakes of 1918 it
will not leave europe permanently
embittered one state against the other i
have both paperback versions of the
first world war in the second world war
written win
the uh second world war i i wrote for
the
1995 anniversary
that must be the
50th anniversary of the end of the war
and the first world war
i wrote
later although i prepared it earlier and
that was published for the
uh
in
1994 on the 80th anniversary of the
start of world war one which was more
difficult
to write
all right you see this is a very
difficult problem i'm one of those
authors i think many authors feel that
every book they write is their favorite
when they write it and you mustn't have
favorites it's like the children you
can't say i prefer my son to my daughter
or my older daughter to my younger son
or whatever
i i feel though perhaps i shouldn't say
this with the other books displayed i
feel that my first world war book is of
all my books
the
the best the most important the one into
which i put
uh something which no other historian of
the first world war had done so all the
fronts are in the war behind the scenes
is in the human stories are in the
poetry's in the pain is in
that was a very special and difficult
book to write and i spent a lot of time
visiting the the different war fronts
and i i felt that i was able to convey
something of the human side not only the
appalling cruelties of the war but also
the heroism which should not be
forgotten
second world war is different second
world war is so far the only history of
the second world war
which has been published in which the
fate of the jews is an integral part of
the story of world war ii and i i was
determined to do that
and also for example the story of the
the terrible story of the chinese
suffering in the war
elements of the of the second world war
which were never put into single volumes
before so
and and they're not in as chapters or
footnotes they're woven into the
narrative the chronological narrative of
the war
this email came in uh from kyle nutson
asks how do you compare your respective
books on one world war one and world war
ii with those written by john keegan
well john keegan's also a brilliant
historian and i say also he is a
brilliant historian
we have very different perspectives but
i think both our approaches are very
worthwhile i wouldn't dream of knocking
him or no just i mean does he take
his is a different he he he doesn't
he doesn't do quite the chronological i
i believe that history
uh makes sense when cause and effect can
be shown from day to day things happen
from day to day
and therefore i've always been against
that it's a very
powerful way of writing history of
chapters on different themes
i believe that in a way if you can do it
and you can make it a readable narrative
the
history has to be chronological and
therefore in the case say of world war
ii
uh when you're dealing with the war in
europe and the war in the pacific for
the people at the time the two wars are
being fought at the same time and
therefore you have to find a way of
blending them together and then again
for example pearl harbor
the terrible blow of pearl harbor took
place the day before the first german
death camp
at hellnoi in poland in which jews were
murdered systematically by gas so i
brought those two together i didn't have
one chapter
on the gassy and one chapter on pearl
harbor because it was happening at the
same time
and
people who were in a polish village
about to be
destroyed were conscious and aware and
told of this terrible blow to the united
states by japan and indeed of hitler's
declaration of war on the united states
which in retrospect was surely his
single most
important mistake
tucson arizona go ahead good morning uh
sir gilbert um i was wondering if you
could recommend a book that would more
thoroughly cover churchill from his
personal life rather than his
place in history it seems like every
book deals with his political and and
war career and i'm really interested in
what made him who he is if you could
respond to that thank you well i hope
very much that the personal life is here
if you could see it
the my church will work really i
although of course there's a lot of
politics and war in it i've made sure
that really on every page his personal
life emerges his character his
characteristics his family his
relationships
and and i think you know i hope if you
if you have a chance of looking at that
you'll see from the very beginning from
his early life his school days his
terrible struggles with his father who
regarded him as an idiot
uh his awful struggle with his mother
who had first neglected him and uh
against whom he actually brought a legal
action to stop her squandering the
family money after his father died this
is the correct picture of them correct
i just want to make sure i had the right
and uh so i think you'll find in in
churchilla life you'll get a
a very detailed and fascinating and
sometimes quite disturbing uh
look at this man
and some of the personal problems he was
up against
and how he struggled and how he
really despite his father's contempt for
him
emerged successfully clementine
clementine churchill yes what was her
impact on winston
it was enormous she had the gift
which
one shouldn't perhaps encourage wise or
with this gift
she
could write to him every morning they
never breakfasted together they had a
rule not to breakfast together they
brexed it apart but
they sent each other notes or rather she
sent him constantly notes not only how
he should behave politically but about
his character about his behavior if she
felt he was getting a little bit
aggressive towards his staff
she would make sure that uh
he knew it
once she wrote him a letter saying she
thought that he was behaving appallingly
towards his staff he was too rough he
was too brusque she tore it up into
little pieces she threw in the waste
paper basket she picked it out of the
waste paper basket she stuck it together
again and four days later she gave it to
him and she was full of ideas
during wars she was urging him to become
a great peacemaker uh in peace time she
was urging him to become a great social
reformer she she had a tremendous gift i
mean she loved him dearly but at the
same time she saw that a man like him
with so many moods and so many different
approaches to life needed perhaps a calm
restraining but persistent hand how much
time did you spend with her i used to
spend a lot of time with i used to go
once a fortnight once every two weeks
down from oxford when i started my work
and would have lunch with her
and then read her what i'd written and
she she was wonderful because it was my
job to uh
it was my job
to get the history right but she could
convey emotion and feeling if she talked
about a politician
she spoke in such a way that i would
almost look around the room see that he
must be there the intensity of her
feelings and emotions whether praise or
blame she was very critical for example
of roosevelt who she felt simply wasn't
spending enough hours of the day
focusing on the war compared with her
husband what year did she die
she died in in the 80s in in her own 80s
in her own late 80s
next call is from boston hello
go ahead boston
yes i have a question um i'm one of
those who was bothered to read
the uh the entire transcripts of the
irving versus lipstat trial
and
i think it may some pretty interesting
and remarkable points i'm sure that you
followed the trial as well perhaps you
could give us your impressions and
opinions of the case thanks what was
that case
well this was a case where david irving
who's a revisionist historian and a
racist
uh brought an action against deborah
lipstadt an american academic at emory
university in atlanta georgia who had
written a very good book about those who
denied the holocaust and irving was one
of the characters
who she really exposed and revealed his
uh his racist and uh
and appalling distortion of history to
try to
not only deny the holocaust but create
hitler into a hero and he decided to
bring a live election against her which
is something he was able to do in the
british courts
and actually i just had a massive heart
attack and a triple heart bypass and my
cardiologist said there's no way that
you can work at your desk you can't lift
up books and papers but you need a bit
of cardiovascular activity why don't you
go to the irving lipstick trial so i
attended pretty well every day of the
trial one or two days and i wasn't well
enough to go
and it was very impressive above all to
see how a person with strong racist
views would reveal them and expose them
and glory in them and revel in them
rather than try to
mask them or disguise them or justify
them in some sophisticated way and the
other impressive thing was british
judges are thought of as being rather
dim
and stupid and prevaricating and when
the judge
was
asking irving questions i thought well
this man really understands the history
he understands that the
that history is black and white a phrase
i used earlier that there is such thing
as true history you can't have a half
evil hitler and a half good hitler
you can't have a holocaust which
did take place or didn't take place
and the judge understood that and in his
final judgment uh instead of again
prevaricating and saying well there are
points on both sides he he came out very
firmly against any falsification of
history it was a very powerful case
next call is santa cruz
uh hi dr gilbert uh it's an honor to be
able to talk with you
first of all let me say uh
we love c-span and c-span 2 and book tv
and
we love watching this every sunday on
programs of this nature but dr gilbert
my wife and i had the pleasure of
visiting chartwell last summer
and
we've written much of with the churchill
particularly the history of the second
world war but you'd made a comment about
the coming together of europe and the
like
and a number of folks that we've talked
to recently seem to think that in terms
of
france and germany and the like there's
a
kind of what you might term a new
anti-semitism ruling in its head i'd be
interested to hear what your thoughts
are on that
well first of all you mentioned
chartwell and in my book in search of
churchill the final chapter is me
walking around church chartwell with my
son david and trying to explain to to
him
uh
about churchill through going around the
house and in fact the uh the photographs
of chartwell including one of
churchill's bedroom all taken by my son
so chart well i can recommend anybody
who's in england to go there it's a
house which
really does preserve churchill's
churchill's mood and churchill's
sense and how long did he live there
he bought it in in 1924 just after world
war one and he he lived there until his
death uh
40 years later and it was a haven for
him in fact during the
second world war there were two
occasions when the war was going really
badly
and
it was unclear how britain could survive
the massive german bombing and the
prospect of a german invasion
and churchill went down to chartwell on
those occasions to be totally alone and
to try and commune a little with his
home with the
wonderful ponds which he had himself
built
and it was a source of great solace to
him of course he did a lot of painting
there
and he also brick he built bought built
buildings there he was a bricklayer he
uh built his studio and he painted in
his studio
that chartwell as for your other
question
i i can't really answer it i i am a
historian i i'm not a
i'm not someone who deals with
contemporary affairs i'm not a
journalist i
i haven't myself come across
anti-semitism but then i live to a
certain extent in an ivory tower i work
in archives i write at my desk
i haven't come across it myself
and i don't think the story i can talk
about anti-semitism in france and
germany in the 19th and 20th centuries
and i've written about that extensively
but i really don't know what the current
situation is
is it possible for someone of jewish
heritage to write
a completely unbalanced history
of jewish history and the holocaust well
that's very interesting question because
first of all i believe there is such a
thing
as
professional history academic standards
which are based upon archives and
documents and the honest use of
documents
and that historian whatever his
ethnic or racial or cultural or
religious origins if he's a professional
historian if he's he's been properly
trained and he
deals properly with his profession
he will be guided by what he finds not
by what he has in the back of his brain
uh he will be guided by the documents i
i'd mentioned the
the the jews who played appalling parts
in imposing uh communism in eastern
europe or or even uh i think i mentioned
those who had played a part in the
tyranny and the
in imposing tyranny on the soviet union
so now as a jew obviously i'm very
uncomfortable
since i'm not a communist i'm very
uncomfortable when i come across that
but i don't say
well i must mask it or eliminate it or
even modify it you have to tell it
as it was
so i i was criticized curiously uh by
one british reviewer when
my volume five of the churchill
biography came out and volume five the
church biography dealt with his
anti-nazism and this reviewer said it
was very interesting criticism
that as a jew i couldn't write
accurately about churchill's anti-nazism
which this reviewer felt was exaggerated
he felt that neville chamberlain
appeasement coming to terms with hitler
was a better way forward he said i
couldn't write uh fairly about that
because as a jew i had a a natural
sympathy with churchill being
sympathetic for the jews and and i
thought well that's it's a clever
argument but it isn't true because
had churchill been pro-nazi and i was
the church of biography i would have
written about that as well the fact that
he was anti-nazi is a fact of life it
had nothing to do with me being jewish
that i told the story on the other hand
some reviewers have taken umbrage with
the fact that you don't go into your
history and come out with conclusions
right you know that
that you don't make conclusions in your
history sometimes hey you know all i get
is the facts well it's not strictly true
i think all you know again i mean the
the nature of the historian's craft is
that you you are selecting material and
you're selecting it with a view to
guiding the reader towards what you
believe are the correct conclusions from
the historical evidence and i think in
all my books first of all i
i always conclude that
in the struggle between tyranny and
democracy uh tyranny has the greatest
advantage because the tyrant knows what
he wants much more clearly than a
democrat so that's one of my constant
conclusions then another of my
conclusions is that which again i've
articulated again and again is that the
individuals do matter and not only the
individual leaders
churchills the roosevelts the stalins
but also the man in the street that the
voice of the man in the street the
articulation of the man in the street
and when i was writing my history of
20th century for example about the fall
of communism i very much concluded that
this was a popular
uh
uprising one which essentially was was
without bloodshed
and uh you know so i i'm concluding all
the time and uh and in my holocaust work
i also conclude that the uh
that although the jews were victims and
six million jews were murdered i come to
the conclusion that there was a spirit
there there was a determination
sometimes seen in resistance sometimes
in spiritual resistance in maintaining
one's humanity and these i say are
important elements in the human
condition that we're not merely pawns
even when we're very weak and being
pushed about like pawns on a chess board
we still have the qualities of the kings
and queens on the board
tidewater virginia you're next to hello
thank you for taking my call i'd like to
compliment you all for your fine show
professor gilbert i'm a high school
history teacher and i have a question
for you my students currently are
studying world war ii but my question
pertains to world war one but what if
any were the political ramifications of
the guillotine campaign with winston
churchill and his involvement in that
the planning and so forth thank you very
much
again i mean i in volume three of the
churchill biography if you if you get it
from your public library since
unfortunately it's out of print but it
is in the public libraries volume three
of the church box i deal extensively
with gallipoli
it was considered to be
uh
really evidence of this man's uh lack of
judgment
uh he was only 40 years old
he had risen really to the pinnacle of
british
life he was at the
inner war cabinet he was a member of the
inner war cabinet
but because he he really was so
determined to try to knock turkey out of
the war and open up a a second front as
it were against
germany and austria hungary from the
danube from the black sea from the south
it was considered that he was obsessed
by it
ironically although it led this is your
question it led to him being knocked out
of uh the center stage of british
politics and it led to lifelong
criticisms by people that his judgment
was awry
even at the time there was a hardcore of
people
who felt that this really was the way
forward that its failure was bad luck
not bad judgment and it was
extraordinary on churchill's 80th
birthday when he appeared in westminster
hall
and uh
both houses of parliament and thousands
of people were gathered there to to
praise him
clement atlee the labor leader who
succeeded him as labour prime minister
in 1945 who defeated him in that
election clement actually chose to
choose gallipoli as an example of
churchill's genius and he called it the
one great idea of the war which had it
come to fruition could have shortened
the war so churchill always had his
supporters and he always believed in it
and indeed he devoted a lot of his
writing time a lot of his memoir writing
time to trying to justify it and one of
the most exciting things when i was
doing churchill volume 3 and i've also
tried to convey this in in the single
volume churchill life was to be able to
go to the archives and find that many of
the things that churchill believed would
vindicate him did appear in the archives
that he had himself not known the extent
to which this enterprise had so nearly
succeeded how extensive are churchill's
papers
well when i started working on them uh
in 1968 they were moved from randolph
churchill's house
in suffolk
to oxford and they were housed by the
bodily library in oxford for me
and they had to be brought over in
two pantechnicons two great trucks with
a police escort and they weighed 15 tons
weight
these are just his own personal papers
personal papers and the day came in 1988
i remembered exactly because it was my
birthday the 25th of october 1988 when i
turned the last page of the last file
of the last town of the last ounce
of these papers
and they make up probably 50 of my other
material in my church biography but the
other 50 which i suppose you would say
is another 15 tons
worth to be sifted
is the hundreds of archives probably as
many as a thousand archives including
many here the wonderful archives in in
washington the archives of the
presidents and one of my greatest
discoveries uh personally i went into
the new york public library
in 1965 when i was still working for
randolph and i knew from churchill's
papers that he had correspondence with
an american called burke cochran a
tammany hall boss and that clearly from
cochran's letters to churchill churchill
sent him many letters and the young
churchill 25 years old had been deeply
influenced by cochran so i went to the
new york public library where they had
cochran's papers and said can i see the
correspondence with winston churchill
and cochran and the lady came back and
said well we have a correspondence with
winston churchill but it's not the
british winston churchill it's the
american novelist there was one called
winston churchill who wrote about 20
novels so i left the library very
disappointed but as i left it was a
terrible thunderstorm and i didn't have
a raincoat or an umbrella so i went back
and i said well let me read the american
novelist winston churchill centers and
she brought up a box of my winston
churchill's letters they had misfiled
them they didn't realize they were
sitting on this treasure and there for
example the letter written by churchill
on his 25th birthday
the 30th november 1899 from a prisoner
of war camp in south africa
describing to cochran how damnable it
was to be a prisoner as he put it when
so little time is left for me he thought
he was going to die at the age of 40
because all the members of his family
had died young
and he writes to cochran and he says
there's one thing i want to do if i can
get out of here and that is to make sure
that the
the era of merchant capital is ended
and the era of productive industry is
begun
west hi it's real maryland you're next
with sir martin gilbert thank you for
taking my call my fan
the holocaust museum had an exhibit
that showed how the country of denmark
as a whole
resisted persecution of its jewish
nationals
during the occupation of by the nazis
and later i learned that bulgaria also
as a country resisted in the same way
would you comment about in two ways uh
what it was about the makeup of these
two countries that led to their position
positions and conduct and contrastingly
why other nations did not
i'll do that with pleasure uh i'm i'm
publishing next week believe it or not a
book on this very subject called the
righteous
it's being launched in new york
on
in next week
and it's my newest book and it deals
with the danish and bulgarian cases
and i think the answer to the question
is
it is very interesting
first of all the bulgarian government
which refused the deportation of almost
50 000 bulgarian jews an enormous number
in fact bulgaria was the only country
which ended world war ii with more jews
living in it than it began
um
bulgaria was not under german occupation
it was allied to germany
and bulgarian troops were at that time
fighting alongside the germans against
russia
but the germans depended upon these
governments of the government of
bulgaria
to
agree to put jews on the trains and
deport them and the bulgarians refused
and it was the bulgarian church the
bulgarian orthodox church played an
enormous part in this the bulgarian
labor unions paid an enormous part
bulgarian farmers
and the king who was himself german had
to bow to this this pressure
particularly a vote in the parliament
so that that was possible because
germany
did not occupy bulgaria in the case of
denmark it was a much smaller number of
jews less than 5 000
but there it was a german the german
naval
representative
in denmark who's in charge of shipping
uh georg dukkwuds and he
learned what was happening and he was a
decent german as so many germans were
in a way the ordinary germans were just
as decent and straight as ordinary
people everywhere
and duquesne first flew
to sweden where he persuaded the swedish
government to allow the jews to come in
if they could be smuggled across the
water from denmark and then he went to
the danish resistance and the danish
jews and alerted them i mentioned the
danish resistance because also in norway
although there were deportations from
norway
more jews were smuggled out of norway to
sweden by the norwegian resistance then
were taken to the camps and killed
other countries like italy and hungary
resisted successfully the deportation of
any jews but then the time came when the
development of the war was such
that in 1943
germany occupied italy and in 1944
occupied hungary and then of course
it was you know they could use the
apparatus of the ss and the gestapo for
the deportations the tragic stories and
the ones which contrast worst with
bulgaria and denmark which you mentioned
are countries like france where while
there was a tremendous french resistance
and many more french jews were saved by
christians in france including by the
christian church
nevertheless the government was pro
german the vichy government and
collaborated and used its police forces
to collaborate in the deportation of
jews some of the pictures from
sir martin gilbert's new
book
the righteous that he talked about and
these are the pictures of you as you
said ordinary people
these are not any big names that people
are going to know
though there were some big names curious
enough prince philip's mother uh who is
princess alice of greece she hid jews in
her house in athens and saved them even
though senior
germans were coming to her house because
she was a princess
and were
being entertained by her were these
people hard to find
these people well you know it's it's
fantastic you say that because
all the p all the christians who rescue
jews who i've had dealings with or
correspond with or met
are so modest they do not feel that they
did anything heroic they feel simply
that they did the decent thing
the humane thing to do
and therefore they are hard to find
because they're not thrusting themselves
forward like so many people in our
societies they're not thrusting and
clawing for honors and recognition
and they're often very surprised when
you say to them that you did a heroic
deed no no they said i just did what any
human being would do someone's life was
in danger
and i saved them i tried to save them
scottsdale arizona you're next
yes good morning
my opinion of winston churchill was
totally opposite of popular opinion i
believe he was a drunken blowhard and
drunken what
a drunken buffoon
yes if he had made a deal if he had made
a deal with germany in 1940 we have a
better role today i mean even the jews
may have fared better they may have been
deported instead of exterminating
because everybody knows that hitler
started exterminating the jews out of
his frustration by not achieving victory
over russia and we would have a better
world today if germany had been
victorious even the acts even the
africans and the third world nations
there would be a lot fewer of them but
they would live a better but
africa would be an orderly continent
instead of the mess that it is today if
germany was in control if germany had
been victorious we'd have a better world
today that that is my opinion and uh and
i'm not alone in this and david urgen is
by far the best historian of world war
two bar none
mr albert
well first of all you started by saying
he was a drunken buffoon he certainly
wasn't a drunkard
he enjoyed wine and he enjoyed uh
spirits but
he never overdrank he was always totally
in command of the
thousands and tens of thousands of
important meetings he had to preside
over
and he never had problems in reading a
document or forming a view
a buffoon he wasn't because he was a
serious person he had a nice sense of
humor
but a buffoon he was not
as to
the idea that had hitler
been able to make peace with churchill
in 1940 something which you you rightly
uh
imply churchill resisted he refused to
contemplate any negotiations with hitler
in 1940
i think it would have been disastrous
you say for example the jews were only
exterminated after hitler failed to
conquer russia but actually he began
exterminating the jews from the very
first day of his victorious march into
russia we should probably tell our
viewers where they can also see a lot of
the photos that we're showing today and
that is one of your books which is a
photographic portrait when did you do
this
just a photographic portrait i did on my
back i i damaged my back and i was lying
in bed and i couldn't continue work on
the church biography because that
required sitting at a desk and moving
documentary files
and i had all these boxes of photographs
so i lay on my back and i devised a sort
of trolley system so the pictures could
come up above me
and uh
i the the main interest really i think
in the in these pictures and it it shows
how
this was done in the 70s and we're now
in the new century so about 30 years ago
in those days people were not
particularly interested in any
historical photographs many of these
were glass plate negatives which
newspapers were throwing out as they
wanted to clear their shelves they threw
out their
their photographs and so i would go
around the photographic archives
nowadays because every glass plate
negative is treasured and put in museums
and isaiah please be able i think to
give a nice portrait of churchill in the
round photographically
well i was just showing some some of the
photos from this book uh with churchill
and fdr in recent history there's been
discussion and comparison of churchill
and fdr
with george bush and tony blair
what do you think of those comparisons
well
bush and blair have the job which fdr
and churchill had
um
are there any further comparisons than
that
well i i had of a i say fortunate
actually a year ago to to spend a little
time in the oval office with with george
bush and i met his father
some 10 years earlier i suppose
and i must say i was rather impressed
first of all i think both bush and blair
although they're very different
characters they're different types of
people obviously and have very different
political backgrounds
they both do take the moral aspect
of current affairs of their
responsibilities very seriously
it's very easy for a prime minister or
president to say well this isn't
really my business i remember vividly
when from the archives when churchill
went to see eisenhower
and begged eisenhower to try to minimize
the cold war by
having a summit with stalin's successors
and i now simply dismissed it he wasn't
interested in it he didn't see that this
was a way forward
and i think you know both bush and blair
have this tremendous sense of moral
purpose
uh
they both believe that the world can be
a better place i mean you and i can
argue until the cows come home whether
this is the way to make it a better
place but they both believe it and i
think this is tremendously important and
i'd like to feel that blair since he's
my prime minister
is is a positive influence on bush just
as margaret thatcher is said to have
been a very strong influence indeed it
comes in my 20th century book on on
bush's father because blair also he's a
devout christian he's a man of very
serious purpose and he would like to see
the world a better place and it's
interesting the previous questioner was
was saying something about africa being
in emmaus and and recently george bush
has announced an initiative with regard
to aids in africa and blair also in one
of his most important sort of
presentations of what he believes in
about a year ago now also said that it's
the duty of of statesmen of wealthy
countries and powerful countries like
britain united states to raise africa up
from the terrible pit into which it has
fallen so
you know there may be quite a lot more
in common than one thing was there were
there any questions or a discussion that
you had with president bush when you saw
him in the oval office uh about any
particular point in history
well he was very interested in churchill
and he asked me to to lecture to his
staff uh in a wonderful uh library uh
there
about how
churchill had dealt with the pressures
of what is the equivalent today of the
al-qaeda and
weapons of mass destruction
and it's interesting you know that he
does he does have a sense that there is
something in history from which i mean
you can't really learn from history but
you can you can be guided by history i
mean history won't tell you how to
behave but it'll show you the sort of
pitfalls and the parallels and and also
in in this particular case you know you
could be and this was not so long after
september 11. you you can be in in a
very
desperate and confused and troubled
state
but you can also have some vision
uh for how you can emerge from that and
i think that was churchill's great
strength that when the british public
were really being battered by the german
daily bombardments and of course as many
as 50 000 british civilians were killed
in the german bombardment the church was
able to talk not only about we'll get
through this we'll survive it but there
will be victory in the end you know we
we will try not just us not just our
armies but our way of life our belief
and so on and i think the american
democracy like the british democracy
are fortunate to have leaders who
believe in the democracy
uh next is burtonsville maryland
hi connie go ahead hi how's it going you
thank you for seeing spanish thank you
for your time mr gilbert
um i just finished edward wizinski's um
in-depth biography on joseph stalin
and at the very end he wrote that
stalin's great dream
ever since i guess he
took power
after london's death was
to begin world war iii after defeating
fascism after defeating hitler's nazi
germany
and
do you know if this is true that he
wanted to exterminate jews in russia and
ship them out to siberia from the
caucuses and if i guess from ukraine
and that would trigger world war three
with the west because there was a
prominent jewish influence in america at
that time
and
this was his whole um idea
ever since 1924 i guess thank you very
much sir
right you know edward rozinski is a you
know has done a lot of work in in the
soviet archives and if if that's what he
found then appalling though it is it it
may be the case certainly it seems to be
true that stalin did have
a very evil plan
for deporting the jews to siberia he had
decided
that the time had come somehow to deal
in his way with what he called the
jewish question as hitler had done with
extermination he would do it by
deportation to siberia where
you know life was nasty brutish and
short and one of the things which which
incidentally had brought church and
truman together immediately after
roosevelt's death
was the discovery that stalin intended
his troops that already reached germany
had reached berlin
he intended to make a parachute drop on
denmark and to seize denmark so in other
words he didn't have a sense in his mind
that there was a an eastern europe and a
western europe and he would control the
east and the west could be left with its
own devices so they knew that he had
that type of imperialistic
aim
santa barbara california
yes mr gilbert
isn't it true that during
world war one and after world war one
there was a
movement
in the arts and in literature
i'm talking about the dada
movement and the surrealist movement
after world war one that pretty much uh
questioned the uh
the idea of the romantic ideals that may
have
led to
uh
world war one
also
wasn't there a movement after world war
ii such as in the beat generation
that
after the development of the atomic bomb
a great deal of pessimism towards the
liberal
ideal
of uh
of humanism uh that led to these these
great
world wars
i think you're right i i think you're
absolutely right and i think it it it
worked both ways on the one hand you had
sort of flower power you had people who
believe that you could
somehow buy art and by culture and by
music uh
change the
the sort of harsh aspect of the age but
then you also had people who believe
that it could be done
by some form of totalitarian regime and
uh i think the great difficulty in
churchill once said in
in the early 30s the must between the
doctrines of comrade trotsky and hair
goebbels be somewhere for you and me
and others who feel like us to to live
and it's always been difficult i think
in not just in the 20th century but
certainly in the 19th century and many
movements anarchism was another one
assassinations which have gone on
into our day
cruel assassinations people who felt
that by disturbing the equilibrium you
could also bring about i don't know a
better society or a different society
but it seems to me that the liberal
impulse
uh although as you rightly say
had its part in
both world wars
it is still
essentially a defensive impulse
and a live and let leave impulse it's
not totalitarian and it's not imperial
this is our in-depth program our guest
this month is martin gilbert we take our
next call from dallas texas
thank you i would be interested in mr
gilbert's opinion of william
manchester's biography it's two two
volumes out of a plan three
of churchill
and also his opinion as a historian of
churchill as a historian i'll hang up
and listen thank you
well unfortunately william manchester
has been very ill and
unable to complete the third of his
volumes
like lord jenkins's biography of
churchill it derives very heavily from
my own work and uh
you know i'm pleased that that should be
the case because you know obviously
william manchester is a
best-selling author
but i think that the
portrait of churchill that he presents
is sometimes a little distorted
well for example he
portrays churchill as something of a
racist which he was not and
he derived some material from my book
which pointed in that direction but
ignored the material which very
emphatically pointed
in the other direction in fact churchill
you mentioned asked about churchill's
historian church was i think a much
better historian first of all because he
never uh
he never hid the fact that when he was
writing his histories he was putting his
point of view
but more importantly he he had an
extraordinary i and you won't find it
for example in the memoirs of
of almost any politician that that i've
read
churchill believed that
there had to be a documentary basis even
for his own
story even for putting his own side and
sometimes those documents were not
necessarily
helpful or complementary to him and he
didn't shy from using them so he
combined a brilliant use of language
with
a use of documents which is very rare
and very remarkable
next is uh pacific south palisades
california go ahead good morning
terrific program
uh so martin my question is can you
describe who john churchill or the first
duke of marlborough was historically and
what impact
uh winston churchill's knowledge of him
um how that impacted churchill's
development and what he saw as his role
vis-a-vis nazi germany and
the progression of history during uh
during his lifetime i'll hang up and
listen and thanks again for terrific
program take care
who was john churchill john churchill
was an ancestor of winston churchill's
and uh he was born in in the 17th
century
uh he was a very remarkable figure he
was a military figure he was a political
figure
um
he
became first duke of marlborough and his
victories essentially over the french
uh led to him uh being given blenheim
blenheim palace
uh by the nation
and churchill was a direct descendant of
john churchill first duke of marlborough
and indeed there was a very short period
john churchill's early life when had
there just been two deaths in the family
he would have become duke of marlborough
and then of course under british
constitution could never become prime
minister
the the writing of of churchill's life
of his ancestor by churchill
it's a remarkable work he he began it
when he himself was in the political
wilderness
uh the 10-year political wilderness
beginning in 1929
and as churchill wrote it he became more
and more struck by the fact
that what his ancestor had done
was to form a coalition of states
against
france which was then the dominant and
tyrannical power in europe and the
conquering power in europe and so it
gave churchill quite a strong basis for
his own advocacy
of
an alliance of threatened states against
hitler
and he argued for that
but failed to create it the government
of the day wanted appeasement it wanted
to get on better terms with adolf hitler
and so churchill's example of his
ancestors success in forming a grand
coalition
against the dominant power failed but it
was an important lesson for him there
was another aspect of his writing of the
life of of mobile which i i might
mention and that is when he was doing
his researches he went to marlborough's
battlefields and he went to the
battlefield
of blenheim
and he stayed in munich and while he was
in munich doing his historical research
adolf hitler who was then within a few
months of coming to power asked to see
him and uh churchill told the
intermediary of course he would see
hitler but he would like to ask him he
should
let hitler know in advance he'd like to
ask him why he was so hostile to the
jews
and hitler uh
came to the hotel
church was dying there he'd invited
hitler to join him after dinner he
looked down i've been to the balcony
where hitler looked down on churchill
and his party and
and hitler then decided to go away he
didn't want to perhaps discuss
anti-semitism with churchill because
church was known to be
very angry at anti-semitism he did not
like anti-semitism and so
as churchill said hitler lost his one
opportunity of meeting me
and churchill later used to reflect
thank goodness hitler did not come down
to that dining table
say i had been charmed by him so many
british politicians and others were
charmed by hitler it was a master of
diplomatic charm and so hit hitler
failed to have a chance to charm
churchill and church was relieved by
that it meant that he wasn't tainted by
any uh
sympathy which it was so easily
generated with his visitors the winner
of world war one in britain david lloyd
george
uh went to see hitler and hitler charmed
him
and lloyd george therefore was not
willing perhaps to speak out as strongly
against him as he might have done sag
harbor new york
uh yester martin a question regarding
the research and uh writing of your new
book
uh in the course of that did you find
that the book a couple years ago by
david jonah goldhagen i think his name
was about the german
germans willing executioners
was
very much the fact or did you find that
you personally in your research see a
difference between your book
and that book or are these two things
that ran on parallel tracks at the same
time
thank you very much
well i've got a lot of respect for for
daniel goldhagen and he's a historian
and this is equality and historians who
feel very passionately
about what he is presenting i do take
issue with him and i think my
my book the righteous the new book
uh in a sense answers uh
some of his concerns i'd like to feel
that uh
he might be influenced by it
in that it shows that uh there were
people in germany
who
despite the terrifying pressure of the
gestapo and the tyrannical regime
took enormous risks and did
save jews and did try to help jews and
indeed i've got a chapter in the book in
in in the new book the righteous i've
got a whole chapter in it about germans
who as the victors and the master race
were in many countries occupied by
germany
and they too many of them also
made enormous efforts such as schindler
whose story is well known but many other
schindlers uh germans outside germany in
the conquered lands who instead of
behaving as vicious conquerors made
tremendous efforts to try to save jews
not only individual jews but sometimes
dozens and even hundreds of jews so
i i do believe that's another side of
the coin that
you know the germans certainly weren't
collectively guilty but there were many
germans who took great risks to to try
to save jewish lives i've tried to tell
that story
have you found this is an email question
for you have you found that ultimately
the causes of the wars of the 20th
century were economic or was the love of
money the root of all evil
no easy questions today
i think that that in a sense nationalism
is is
it's not exclusively the answer
um
i think that the economic
aspect does come in because of course
germany felt that it had been wrongly
deprived as it had been deprived of land
and economic resources
after world war one by the treaty of
versailles so part of the german desire
for revenge which hitler so brilliantly
exploited
arose
from what could be called economic
factors or the desire for
control of raw materials and so on
but at base i think it's national i
think that the the instinct hitler most
exploited and mussolini most enhanced in
italy was national
the belief that we germans or we
italians are not being given our proper
place in the world our deserved place in
the world mussolini did it by demanding
an overseas empire you know control of
the mediterranean ethiopia north africa
and and hitler did it by demanding
somehow
living room for germans space for
germans respect for germans so i think
nationalism really is the dominant
factor but once the conquest began
you see greed and economic motives begin
to dominate
you find that
the spoils of war become tremendously
attractive indeed when i was doing my
research on world war one
i found a memorandum presented by the
british colonial secretary in charge of
parts of the empire
about what what should we do when
germany is defeated and he actually
headed his memorandum the spoils
there were no bones about it
stanford connecticut excuse me
california
go ahead california oh yes um
professor gilbert my father a scottish
canadian was a pilot in world war one on
the western front and i've found
difficulty in finding good literature on
this
on the air war it seems the trench
warfare predominated and also the
contribution of canada to
world war one is seems to be lacking do
you have any advice for me on either of
those points
well again i'd like to feel that in my
history of the first world war the air
war certainly is there
and also canada
you know canada's role is there in the
role of individual canadians and of the
canadian government
um the
there are books i mean you know if you
perhaps go to the uh to your public
library or your main line but have a
look at mine first and see if you can't
find canada well represented i'm a great
patriotic
proto-canadian because in 1940 when i
was a little fellow three and a half
years old i was sent away from england
and away from my parents
because of the general fear of invasion
by germany
and together with several thousand other
children were sent to canada others came
the united states but i went to canada
so i learned to read and write in canada
i have a great affinity for canada i
like the canadians who did you live with
what was this i lived with a family in
toronto who took me in a jewish family
actually
dr mrs leisner and they had a little
girl a little two-year-old younger than
me who's still alive and who
i saw in toronto two days ago and i'll
see in toronto next week we remain very
close it was remarkable i mean there
were
the children were brought over here
and then
i i found my first sort of con
connection with churchill quite
unexpectedly in the archives he
discovered
in may 1944 that one of the great troop
ships the mauritania which had been
converted into a troop ship was crossing
from new york to liverpool and already
all the american troops for d-day had
arrived in england so there were only
going to be about a thousand troops on
it and it took six or seven thousand so
he
sent a message why not bring all the
children back on the mauritania and make
sure there are enough extra lifeboats
for them
so thoughtful you say so we were all
rounded up and i was put on a night
train from uh union station toronto to
grand st central station and my first
memory of new york is
then seven and a half i was a big boy
and uh all by yourself
at that point in time
together we all met at uh
grand central station and walk through
york it was a hot day
and uh we went down to the docks and
boarded this enormous ship
and of course then the shop was coming
into liverpool on this ship and seeing
the bombed-out shells of
hundreds of thousands of houses in the
liverpool dock area very shocking for a
child there was the worst shock to come
reaching london and in those days they
had satellites morning cinema for
children and i was very excited because
here i was in what for me was a new
country england
and we're going all going to see all the
kids in a crocodile to see tom sawyer
and we went through the street and we
came to the cinema and it had been hit
in the night by a german rocket bomb and
there was this cinema in ruins and the
great banner still flapping the tomsoya
banner and i remember thinking this
hitler
is a bad sword
your parents ever talk about their
decision to have you leave them at such
a time i think it was terribly difficult
for them but you know first of all there
was the danger of the bombing and then
there was the danger of invasion and the
government had this scheme they wanted a
million children to be sent away
and unfortunately the germans started
syncing the
the ships up with the children my convoy
was attacked and five of the 15 ships
were sunk
and once they started syncing the ships
with children on
then the government had to abandon the
scheme
does do the feelings of those early
early days ever come into anything you
write here
i think in my little book in search of
churchill which was my personal journey
i think i i tell the story there of uh
of going to canada and this is your
personal this is your story of
covering working with and working on the
documents and the the biography i have a
chapter about working with randolph
churchill i have
my correspondence how i track things
down people who help me
you have another book that is similar to
that
about the holocaust that is your story
well no yes this is an interesting
what happened was i i i
when i started the churchill work full
time in 1968
my university gave me leave of absence
till i finished it and as i haven't yet
finished it i still got five document
volumes to go i'm still on leave of
absence
but i was asked by university college
london
to teach one
term on the holocaust to introduce a
holocaust mma and halfway through the
term
my pupil said would i take them to the
places that uh that i was teaching about
so i actually booked the tickets found
the hotels found the trains and buses
and then i traveled around with them
this is my diary my personal diary and
the readings which i prepared at each
town at each railway station at each
house and field what did you
learn from that experience that you
didn't learn in the archives well i
think first of all i learned i've always
believed that location is is
tremendously important for historians
that you should try to get some feel of
the places where things happen the
proximity of places to each other the
the topography of the places and i think
uh one of the things which really struck
me was the incredible beauty
of the places where these
terrifying things were taking place you
might think you know that somehow
eastern europe is just a flat bog
with gravestones and you know there's
rolling countryside and there are
beautiful fields and hills and uh
that that was sort of shocking and then
the other thing was to find in many of
these places where terrible things
happened very nearby people were
carrying on with their ordinary lives
well i mean in a sense there was nothing
else they could do but carry on with
their ordinary lives but that was rather
shocking very near this crematorium
chimney i mean within sight of it were
farmers and villagers living and tilling
their fields
and having to avert their eyes or
avert their nose from the terrifying
smell but the inspiring thing was that
my pupils half of them were jewish half
of them were not jewish and it was just
and i tried to convey in the book
our involvement with the journey it
wasn't just like looking out
through a picture window or a cinema
screen
uh you know to go with 12 people
to these places and read about them
on the site there's hitler's uh
oh no that's something i'd like and you
know also we found these
synagogues
which had of course been deserted at the
end of the war but the poles had
maintained them they'd kept their their
rules on their beautiful buildings and
no jews at all left in them nobody to
nobody to pray in fact the lad praying
there and that synagogue was one of my
pupils he decided to break the silence
of a whole generation baltimore maryland
you're next go ahead hello uh professor
gilbert
um
concerning the uh dardanelle
debacle
um why do you feel that
churchill uh bore the
run of the blame for that
when there were so many other players
involved uh kitchener who was a national
hero at that time
uh fisher i believe he was a
first sea lord and uh
but i believe the prime minister was
lord george at the time um and then in
the field there was uh admiral karns and
ian hamilton
um
i believe uh churchill was exonerated uh
later on
uh
and i'm a little fogging this area and i
hope you can
clarify
it for me and i believe uh kishner was i
believe he died in a boating accident
before this
uh investigation could uh could be
completed um if you can help me i
appreciate it i'll hang up and listen to
your response
um i i think i found
the answer to your question i i
many people have published diaries about
the period and i i always had a rule it
wasn't easy to to follow my own rule out
not to read not to use printed diaries
published areas but to try to find the
original diaries and there was one diary
by the secretary to the cabin of that
time
and in
the published diary he he says when the
dardanelles becomes the issue how much
he's against it and that's what he
published after the war and i managed to
get hold of his original diary and there
a it turned out that he not only was for
it but was for it before churchill he
was pushing it before the cabinet before
churchill but i found a sentence in the
diary which he didn't publish he decided
that this was not for publication he
said if the dardanelle succeeds
i will get tremendous credit for having
been one of its originators but if it
fails winston will get the blame
and that taught me a lot
the public want to blame a politician
they want to blame a prominent figure
and the conservatives at that time
who hated churchill largely because he
wanted southern ireland to have its
independence and they wanted ireland to
remain under british rule the
conservatives
really milked the dardanelles and turned
it against churchill well those who
rightly say he was exonerated there was
a commission but curiously the
commission was unable to
produce some of the documents which i
produce in my churchill volume
because kitchener who was to have given
evidence and he was the great hero the
secretary of state for war the field
marshal
kitchener was drowned as you mentioned
on his way to russia in a
warship
and just as the dardanelles commission
was taking testimony which would have
been damning to kitchener and would have
redressed the balance in churchill's
favor kitchen was drowned and the
government felt they couldn't
blacken or criticize the name
of someone who was a national hera
and therefore that section of the
dardanelles report was suppressed and
when i was doing my researches i found
it in the archives and it does exonerate
churchill
this email from arlington massachusetts
my knowledge of history has benefited
greatly from several of your many
atlases of history can you comment on
your experience creating and editing
this atlases and how this process has
affected your writings and that is a
great introduction for us to show the
viewers the atlases let me just start
leave on top it's the rutledge atlas of
american history
what are you trying to do here
well i
i try in these atlases to convey all
sorts of aspects of history
of countries histories or international
history which can be mapped uh and it
may be economic history i propose one of
the earlier questions i have for example
maps showing
arms trading and maps showing profits
made in world war one the gold profits
of countries in world war one appears in
my first world war atlas so it's not
only political history of course it's
changing borders but uh i don't know
what map you've got over i i pulled open
the arms sales i had found this one
interesting
this was from 1992 and you have the
complete world whoever this is from the
american the atmosphere american history
and so it focuses on where america sold
arms in 1992 how many million and then
of course in the darkened areas it's the
countries that have uh bought more than
25 million so you can generally see and
then the facing map is is united states
economic aid which is the other side of
that particular coin but to answer your
question i i i was in the british army
we used to have compulsory
national service and so i served my two
years in the british army from 1955 to
957
and i was very interested then in
mapping and of course armies
have a great uh
interest in maps and one of the areas
which i was particularly interested in
was the soviet union and mapping the
changing soviet borders and the
expansion of the soviet union the
divisions of the soviet union uh
what what it was made up of what it had
been through
and so i began to do sketch maps and
when i was teaching at oxford before i
took on the church biography one of my
people said you know why don't you
turn your sketch maps into into little
booklets
and so these first started coming out in
about 1965
and there are 12 atlases and all they've
just been brought back into print eight
of them by by routledge
or a publisher in new york
and i've always believed that maps can
help you understand history it might be
a treaty i've got maps on the treaty of
si i even have a map showing the
american vote
first the american vote to go to war
with germany in world war one and then
the american vote to pull out of europe
and not to support the their side treaty
so somehow i've always believed that you
can
on a single page in a black and white
map
uh convey thoughts for students or just
for people interested in what has
happened in the past
uh just to give you know an idea here
are some maps of the united states in
the american history one you look at the
you compare murder in the united states
in 1991 you look at
death from aids over a 10-year period
state by state
you look at immigration to the united
states from all countries around the
world in that period
and leading states taking immigrants
going back
in the 1989 period and i try you know i
try to update these atlases every five
years or so so this particular new
edition goes right up to last year
and but they are comprehensive history
they try to start at the beginning
and go on till till today and in the one
uh the rutledge atlas of the
arab-israeli conflict you have up until
this map what is this
negotiations for the final step rather
unfortunate
failure of the of the peace talks in the
very last days of uh president clinton's
presidency
when the israeli prime minister barack
and the chairman of the palestinian
authority assa arafat came together at
camp david and this is the final map
which they almost appeared to agree on
and then the negotiations collapsed and
of course the arab is real conflict at
least i think we'll see from the front
because the conflict goes on and on this
edition is the
seventh seventh edition in a way nice to
feel with the arab israel conflict atlas
that one day one could say well now we
need to draw no more maps the conflict
is resolved well jeff rosenfeld has this
email how should we look at the current
arab israeli conflict and any ideas how
this conflict will be settled
well again
i am only a historian and you know
historian has very limited and confined
abilities he is not a prophet
i often think of churchill's remark and
he was a politician also not really a
prophet and he was asked about something
in the future and he said you know
the future though imminent
is obscure
and that is unfortunately the case
on the arab israel conflict i have no
doubt that the conflict will be resolved
i was a great optimist at the time of
the oslo agreements i was a great
optimist at the time of the camp david
agreements
cam david negotiations
my optimism like that and many others
was clearly misplaced
but my feeling is that you know clearly
there will be
two states this two-state solution was
first proposed by britain in 1937 and
unfortunately rejected by the
palestinian arabs
it was proposed by the united nations in
1947 and again tragically rejected by
the arabs but it will come to pass
i believe that the road map what's
called the road map which
the united states and the european union
are supporting and president bush is
putting forward
that this road map which is currently
being discussed
will eventually be the way forward
but it seems historically so far every
way forward has met an obstacle but
there must come a day when the way
forward will will work and who knows
perhaps the current road map will be the
one because both sides are becoming
exhausted by the conflict and
you know you have to try to build a
civil society which is not threatened by
terror and not
bewildered by
uncertainty even as to where borders are
to be
queens new york hello hi um i wanted to
know why hitler who was not german and
did not have any of the physical
so-called aryan qualities why was he so
accepted as a leader of what he uh was
not
you know what he himself was not he was
accepted as such a great as a leader
it's quite a
mystery he
spoke german with a
slightly odd austrian accent not a
particularly pleasant accent as you say
he didn't look
like an area whatever an aryan is meant
to look like he certainly wasn't tall
and blue-eyed and blonde with rippling
muscles
but he had a charismatic appeal he he
came to these people who were
convinced that the world was treating
them badly that they'd been hard done by
as a result of world war one
he spoke to them in an extraordinary
almost
mystical way about how germany would be
revived
he was as you say in austria and he
wasn't even a german but then part of
his appeal was that
he argued that all germans would be
reunited that austria which
under the treaty of versailles could not
be united with germany which had never
been a part of germany he argued that
austria and germany had one destiny and
would be reunited and somehow he created
an excitement and
of course he never revealed
even in his book my camp his
book my struggle he never revealed the
full extent of the evils which he was
prepared to perpetrate have you ever
considered doing a biography of hitler
i i i've often thought about whether i
could would really
be at ease writing a biography of
someone
uh
whose story they were intensely
interesting and of course for any
professional historian the dynamic of
the stories is almost irresistible
but whether i would really like to write
about somebody
with such a negative impact on the world
i've also thought about writing about
stalin
and i wouldn't rule it out but i i don't
think that's the direction i'm going to
go in bakersfield california
thank you uh mr gilbert what can you
tell us about churchill's religious
faith and philosophical outlook i'm
wondering did he perceive god as a
personal force in his life and what was
his most definitive statement on this
broad subject
churchill definitely had a a
respect for
the idea of god the idea of supernatural
forces he was quite a suspicious person
in in the best sense of the word
he
believed that there might well be an
afterlife
he was deeply versed in the bible both
the old testament and the new testament
he felt a certain i think personal
strength from some of the biblical
stories
he
he did consider that there was a god who
was an ultimate arbiter
he also felt that
it was not revealed to human beings
fully the
the nature of god and that human beings
would have to get on as best
they could
but
he had a high moral sense he regarded
what he called
and what was called the judeo-christian
ethic as something very real in his life
he had a deep respect for
the biblical teachings the jewish and
christian ethical teachings
he wasn't a churchgoer he used to say
i've been
a buttress of the church not the pillar
i've supported it from outside
but at moments of great stress and
strain in his life
he definitely thought of god and he
thought of these
supernatural and spiritual forces
this email from bob smith in plymouth
miss uh um michigan says in april 2002
atlantic monthly christopher hitchens
wrote that several crucial wartime
broadcasts by winston churchill were not
done by churchill but by an actor i
hired to impersonate him norman shelley
who played winnie the pooh for the bbc's
children hour ventriloquized
ventriloquized
churchill for history and fooled
millions of listeners perhaps churchill
was too incapacitated by drink to
deliver the speeches himself is this
true
well it's in my book
which i'll
publish one day of the hundred
myths of winston churchill's life
this must be pretty high up on the list
i happen to have photographs of every
speech he ever made of him making it
and there's no evidence whatsoever that
an actor ever impersonated him sometimes
when he broadcast the united states
and the radio waves were not good uh
someone else would read it but the
broadcast would begin this is alvar
lydell reading winston churchill's
latest speech but he made every speech
as for being incapacitated for drink he
never was incapacitated a
drink he spoke in the house of commons
and in his cabinets and so on always
totally sober so that's really another
myth in my 100 myths about winston
churchill i did find one fascinating
piece of evidence by one of his wartime
speeches
which
may be the origin of this myth that an
actor read his speeches and that is i
found a letter from one of his private
staff to another member his private
staff was out of london
at that time of a churchill broadcast
and the man writes to his friend we had
a lot of trouble with the prime
minister's speech today because he
insisted on speaking with the cigar in
his mouth
and many people phoned in to say has he
had a heart attack
so
he he made his own speech and not only
did he make them but unlike some modern
statesmen he wrote all his own speeches
and that's really the important thing
the content of those speeches which he
not only made but wrote and believed in
the content and i think that's why the
british people
and people in occupied europe were
inspired by churchill speeches because
they knew
this was something which came from the
heart these were not words which had
been prepared by a speechwriter they
were the words of this man sometimes
angry and sometimes inspirational and
sometimes full of an incredible hope
which i don't think a speechwriter or an
actor could have captured is there a
myth about the cigars
you know he
he put many more cigars in his mouth
than he smoked
he nearly always had a cigar in his
mouth but
you very seldom see him with
a with a half smoked or three quarter
smoked cigar he was always lighting them
he had a little thing he liked to do i
can't demonstrate it
he liked it he had his cigar and he
loved to sort of roll it
over his coffee cup or his brandy glass
that was a little sort of habit which he
had but he did he wasn't a he likes
cigars but he he very seldom smoked
cigars down to the uh the base that one
you'll find is probably
long out yeah quite good long unlit
okay next call washington dc go ahead
yes mr gilbert uh your work is truly
magnificent
um i was actually just re reading the
holocaust this morning and i've gained
very much from it
i'm
following up on your remarks about the
uh money and the economic drives in the
holocaust right and i just finished
reading
ibm and the holocaust
by
edwin black or edward black
and i and i haven't seen this
information
in any of the standard works and i
wondered why does it take so long for
some of this information
to come to the fore it's never been
mentioned before
well that that's
it's also a tremendously important
question that you ask and it's one
that's concerned me for many years
uh also in my churchill work why does it
take so long for something which
is real and is discovered and is
presented by historian like black
why's it takes so long for it to enter
into the mainstream of historical
writing i don't understand it a lot of
the histories which are published every
few days
uh are so
what should i say old-fashioned they
they
take into account none of the new
material over the past
not just few years but sometimes over
the past two or three
decades it's a terribly different
question i mean one of the pioneering
works
on this economic aspect of the holocaust
of the the way in which the the ss and
the the german military machinery
used the the wealth of the jews uh for
its own purpose one of the pioneering
works was a memoir by a survivor of
auschwitz called rudy verba
his books called i cannot forgive and i
think it was written in in the sixties
and uh verba who had escaped from
auschwitz to bring the news of the camp
to the west
uh wrote very powerfully about this
economic motif but
if you go to the general history of the
holocaust or presentation holocaust very
few of them will mention verbal's work
which is of incredible importance of
pioneering importance and you'll even
find people in uh
in universities you'll mention him you
might say since he's alive and is in
vancouver why don't you have him become
a lecturer at your university and
they'll say oh who's he and so on so
this is a good example of something
which you know must be at least 30 years
more than 30 years published very much
available if you want to get it he's
reprinted it several times
and yet the facts that he presents don't
become an integral part of history
it's a mystery it may be to do with
the laziness of some writers
it may be to do with reluctance to take
on board things which are slightly out
of kilter with what we feel
we know or what we feel ought to be the
case
next is cleveland hello
yes um i would like to preface my
comment by saying that i am a great
admirer of winston churchill
i think he saved the honor of the west
by standing up to hitler but i've always
been disturbed by his role in the area
bombing of german cities most famous
example was dresden
and figures on casualties uh civilian
casualties in germany were i've seen
them from 600 000 to a million and the
anglican church was disturbed by this
during the war as and the royal air
force wasn't uh celebrated for it and
people like arthur harris
the air marshal wasn't
and churchill certainly had a role in
this and it is one aspect of his
life that does disturb me quite a bit
and particularly in light of the fact
that a lot of people question the
military efficacy of this policy
well you know that's again a central
question in churchill's life i have
addressed it in considerable detail in
my work if you have a chance to look at
churchill life or or at the main volumes
of biography volume
6 and 7 of the church biography you'll
find there an extraordinary story and a
very true story
of how
the
area bombing of germany culminating in
in the
killing of some 42 000 germans in
hamburg
was essentially a policy devised
at the request of joseph stalin
which both churchill and roosevelt
really could not resist because stalin
was demanding what was called a second
front he was demanding uh that the
allies land in northern europe uh the
allies felt the chiefs of staff felt
they could not do it until 1944 they
needed at least a million men
in england trained and ready to go and
44 was by far the earliest
and those tremendous propaganda
generated by stalin in the in the
western press demanding a second front
and
stalin then said look if you can't do it
you you must at least bomb the german
cities and it wasn't totally without its
effect on forcing german fighters and
german defenses back from the eastern
front it undoubtedly helped stalin in
the east this took place but when it
reached the height which it did in 42
churchill was among many people who
opposed it and stopped it and then
strategic bombing became the soul uh the
soul bombing
and there was a moment when church was
watching one of the daily royal air
force films of a german city being
bombed taken from above the city was
vupertal and when the lights of the film
went on and all the air
staff were present and waiting for his
comment and all he said was after a long
pause are we beasts
are we taking this too far
and the result was that the the bombing
policy changed to strategic bombing and
this was only once breached and it was
breached
when stalin informed the british
americans
that the germans were
gaining the advantage in eastern silesia
and urged the british americans to bomb
the city of dresden to prevent massive
german reinforcements panzer divisions
which were on their way through dresden
to the eastern front who could have
inflicted a serious defeat on the
russian forces there
this didn't actually reach churchill or
roosevelt it was dealt with by
the uh
targets committee and the
vice chiefs of the air staffs of our
respective countries but the bombing of
dresden was entirely a soviet request
dealt with at a relatively middle level
as all bombing requests were
by targets committee and when churchill
learnt of what had happened in dresden
which he did
about two
weeks later as a result of a report in a
swiss newspaper
he wrote a furious he was very angry a
furious minute saying why was this done
i gave orders that this sort of terror
bombing should cease and it was then
that the air staff explained to him that
it had nothing to do with terror bombing
it was a soviet request
the british americans had been asked as
a matter of urgency to help the soviets
out and had done what they were asked to
do ambler pennsylvania
uh yes uh mr gilbert i wonder if you're
uh familiar with the arthur zieglebaum
affair
uh author zigglebaum was a member of the
jewish labor bond which was the
social democratic party
in
poland
and he was in the warsaw ghetto and he
was smuggled out to london
i believe 42 or 43
to
present the case to winston churchill to
aid the uprising in the jewish in the
ghetto
and he was not even given the
opportunity to meet with winston
churchill
and uh out of protest and out of the
only
avenue opened to him
to voice his case was to commit suicide
this addresses the point that kind of
kind of
is related to what your last speaker
said that with all these bombs falling
on dresden and on hamburg not a single
one
uh not so much as a hand grenade uh
landed in the warsaw ghetto
well you you're it's not really right
what you're saying uh ziegle-bormann and
schwarzbart were the two jewish members
of the polish government in exile
and
at the time of the uh
of the jewish uprising the warsaw ghetto
uprising in april 1943
um
they
did approach the british government
not actually the british government but
the polish government in exile in london
siegel boy never approached or wanted to
approach churchill
what they tried to do and were partly
successful in doing was to persuade the
polish government in exile which was
based in london to instruct its forces
in warsaw there were two
polish resistance forces in warsaw the
communist forces and those related to
the london polls the government in
london to ask them to aid the insurgents
and in part they did do so and uh
so ziegler was not entirely unsuccessful
but he was in despair he was in despair
at the plight of the jews in warsaw
because it was not the allies but the
germans who
had the
military ascendancy
and they crushed that uprising very
brutally and he committed suicide in
despair but actually the polish
government in exile had
tried to respond to his request there
was a lot of debate about that because
there was a strong anti-semitic strain
in the
resistance group in poland which the
london poles represented but actually
there were those in that resistance
group who did try to help and that has
been fully recognized by the survivors
of the warsaw ghetto uprising
particularly
zuckerman who wrote about it antique
zuckerman who wrote about it in his
memoirs this email question from chris
swanka how did it feel to be knighted
you have to be very careful not to
not to have your throat nicked by the
sword so it's quite a
you have to bend it
it's a real it's a real sword why we're
united it was a it was a great uh thrill
and a wonderful moment
uh i was knighted for two reasons i was
knighted for my historical work
but also because i had worked uh
with john major the british prime
minister
and i traveled with him uh abroad on a
number of overseas missions i tried to
help with the briefing papers and and
you know the sort of background to the
negotiation from a policy angle or from
a historical language
the two overlapped i mean
you know all the subjects which were
being dealt with whether it was bosnia
or the middle east they they had the
historical angle which impinged on it
and i came here in fact to washington on
one occasion
and uh to the middle east to to
jerusalem to
i spent time with john major
uh during his visit with with arafat i
sat next to chairman arafat for a day
and spent many hours with the attacker
being so it was an interesting thing and
basically
uh
you know the history and the current
affairs were so intermeshed
uh that i felt rather privileged as a
historian to be asked to make my
contribution not merely you know what
happened in the past but you know what
what does this all mean today and so
john major very kindly
added that to my knighthood that not
only history but international affairs
where do you live today i live in london
and i believe you've got some
photographs
absolutely they're on this your house is
on the screen right now where is it i
was very nervous that it would look
rather messy well it's in in north
london
uh
at the bottom of highgate hill that's my
front door goodness me i haven't seen
this
someone wrote that you live in
unpretentious confusion it looks rather
spartan my current i better put some
pictures up
now this is my little study here is
unpretentious confusion a good it looks
less confused
than normal eight minutes before the
cameraman came in this is where you
write this is where i write that's my uh
computer screen but i've also write in
pen and ink i've got a
always a bottle of ink and some pens i
think we have a picture of that later on
too
what is what do you try to do with this
room to make it an area where you can
write well i've got three floors and
this is my writing floor the next floor
is my archive floor and the top floor is
is where i do my indexing and my maps
and so on and that's just my clock which
has a very nice ding which reminds me
that another half hour has gone by
sometimes i turn the ding off because i
don't like that what about that writing
in pen and ink
how long have you been doing that that's
a nice pop that lady churchill gave me
so my children displayed you have three
three yes
where are they
and these are my books these i
they photographed every one of my titles
along the shelves
does it inspire you to have them on the
shelf
well sometimes it exhausts me to look
like
did i really do all that
there's some of the churchill biography
the multi-volume church of biography
and i'm hoping very much hillsdale
michigan are going to bring it all back
in print that's one of the current
projects
right and there's the last book the
righteous and then these are the books i
when i started putting the books on the
shelves i thought i had one shelf or
book signed by friends
and it's like 50 shells it's rather nice
do you spend most of your time in london
well you know archival work involves a
lot of travel
but i only write in london i've never
been never managed a sort of laptopy
sort of hotel travel writing i ought to
do it but
i can only really write when i'm back
there
with my particularly the reference books
you know the ability to look up you know
people's dates people's correct names
positions people have that's my desk
again
this paper there's some little churchill
artifacts would one find a lot of
churchill artifacts not many no i'm not
i know those are sort of american
bulldogs so they're not really churchill
artifacts i saw uh some pictures of uh
churchill in some of your books
that was brought to me by the sculptor
oscar neymon
it's a maquette which he did for a great
bronze which is a
near chart well at western
but it's just a little heavy and rather
chipped artifact at the moment
when
just to go back to the question of the
bulldogs though uh i saw a picture in
some of your books of rufus yes who is
rufus
winston churchill had a poodle
is that like one of the major
misconceptions that
the english bulldog was uh this is real
was his real dog well he did he i did
find a letter which he wrote to his
father when he was 10 years old
and he said he decided to sell his
bicycle in order to buy a bulldog so
obviously there was a connection even
with the young church and bulldogs but
no he had he had poodle he liked poodles
and pugs he
you know churchill was a versatile man
and and you know there's like one
champagne company now which says he
always drank their champagne
and he did drink their champagne but he
would drink good champagnes from all the
champagne producers but everybody's
trying to say he only smoked half cigars
only drank my champagne and similarly
they may say he only had bulldogs but uh
rufus was a very favorite poodle waikiki
hawaii
yes aloha good morning um
i just would like mr gilbert to comment
on uh
the relationship between churchill and
ireland the irish people
then also
could he talk about churchill's wit and
sense of humor
for some reason maybe i'm the only one i
he reminds me of benjamin franklin or
something
thank you i mean nope by by that you
mean no sense of humor
i'm sorry he's already gone again
the sense of humor
yes um
the the irish story is brilliant because
uh i've always felt it was churchill's
greatest strength
that he
uh although he was a conservative as a
young man and the conservatives were
determined to retain the unity of
ireland to make sure that britain would
rule the whole of ireland
churchill from his late 30s
came to the conclusion that ireland
ought to be independent
and
i've no doubt that his most important
set of speeches in the house of commons
until world war ii
were the speeches he made in 1921 and
1922
to persuade a basically hostile house of
commons
that ireland had to be independent that
southern ireland had to be given its
immediate independence and that northern
ireland the counties of ulster would
have eventually to become a part of a
united ireland and it's interesting that
both
john major and tony blair
john major through the
downing street declaration and tony
blair through the good friday agreement
essentially have moved forward
from the
churchill's legislation which
established southern ireland as an
independent state they've moved forward
to the concept of an eventually united
ireland which was at the preamble of
churchill's legislation he was hated by
the conservatives for that it led really
to to terrible problems for him
politically but he believed that the
irish had the right to govern themselves
just as ironically he believed the
indians had the right to govern
themselves but he didn't think he was
being done in the right way by the
governments of the 1930s he wanted to
find a way in which india could remain
united and not break up into india and
pakistan and then govern itself
we are two hours into our three-hour
conversation with martin gilbert we're
going to be back in just a few moments
with more of your calls and questions
we're going to be talking about his
first book the appeasers which is now
this year 40 years old we'll be back in
just a few moments to continue
in depth with martin gilbert we'll
continue in a moment
next month on in depth susan sontag will
spend three hours with the novelist sas
playwright filmmaker and theater
director
her books include the way we live now on
photography in america
styles of radical will
where the stress falls and the soon to
be released regarding the pain of others
join us sunday march 2nd live at noon
eastern as we go in depth with susan
sontag
and now for this week's 10 best-selling
non-fiction books from the new york
times
after premiering on the list last week
radio talk show host michael savage
jumps to number one this week with the
savage nation
next former white house speechwriter
david frum describes the first year of
the bush administration in the right man
author pope bronson explores the search
for personal fulfillment in number three
what should i do with my life
and that's followed by number 4
leadership by former new york city mayor
rudolph giuliani
bush at war journalist bob woodward's
behind the scenes look at the white
house response to 911 is number five
sixth is portrait of a killer crime
novelist patricia cornwell deduces that
artist walter sickert is the infamous
jack the ripper
stupid white man by author and filmmaker
michael moore is number seven
maintaining its position at number eight
is 1421 former british submarine
commander gavin menzies alleges that the
chinese discovered and colonized america
before columbus
the conquerors by historian michael
beschloss is number nine
and premiering this week at number 10 is
the memoir of journalist hunter s
thompson kingdom of fear
for more information visit the new york
times website at
nytimes.com and click on books
this year marks the beginning of the
200th anniversary celebration of the
lewis and clark expedition
today on book tv join a panel of writers
along the lewis and clark trail
learn what it was like to study the
expeditions of meriwether lewis and
william clark from historians william
least heat moon dayton duncan james tom
and stephanie ambrose tubbs
lewis clark and the opening of the
american west are on book tv today at 3
pm eastern
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals
head south in february for much ado
about books in jacksonville florida
ken starr bob schieffer and jane levy
are among the featured speakers
then it's springtime in london for uk
booksellers march 16th to 18th is the
london book fair england's largest
industry event of the year
back on home soil the following weekend
in charlottesville for the virginia
festival of the book
now in its ninth year promoting literacy
and celebrating reading and books
begin april at the hall of fame museum
in phoenix the site of this year's
arizona book festival
april 11th and 12th join the c-span
school bus in bowling green for the
southern kentucky festival of books
and on the 26th and 27th head for the
west coast and the los angeles times
festival of books
this eighth annual event will feature
mitch album and louise bardock pope
bronson jane smiley and many others
please let us know about book fairs and
festivals in your area and we'll add
them to our list
email us at book tv at csband.org
[Music]
the national book critic circle is an
organization of professional book
reviewers and book review editors
here in no particular order are their
nominees for best biography or
autobiography
charles darwin the power of place by
janet brown
focuses on the second half of the
naturalist's life including the
controversy surrounding his evolutionary
theories
the master of the senate is the third
installment of robert carro's
multi-volume biography of lyndon johnson
it chronicles johnson's 12 years in the
u.s senate
the last american man by novelist and
journalist elizabeth gilbert relates the
story of eustis conway who spent the
last 20 years in the appalachian
mountains living off the land
benjamin franklin by historian edmund
morgan depicts the life of the 18th
century inventor author and statesman
and the history of the carter family is
profiled by mark swanitzer with charles
hershberg in will you miss me when i'm
gone the carter family and their legacy
in american music
the finalists in the area of general
nonfiction include war is a force that
gives us meaning
it's foreign correspondent chris hedges
examination of humanity's fascination
with combat
william longoesha recounts the
post-september 11th cleanup of ground
zero in american ground unbuilding the
world trade center
samantha power examines the united
states response to 20th century acts of
genocide in a problem from hell
richard rodriguez reflects on hispanic
life in america in his memoir brown and
edison's eve a magical history of the
quest for mechanical life by gabby wood
traces the history of the inventions
that prefigured current experiments with
robotics and artificial intelligence
winners of the national book critic
circle awards will be announced in late
february
for more information visit their website
at bookcritics.org
in depth with martin gilbert continues
we're back with our on in-depth program
for this month our guests are martin
gilbert the author of over 70 books the
official biographer of winston churchill
but you cover the complete century
pretty much i try to
back to your first book this this
emailer called in and said would you
please discuss your book the appeasers
and what motivated you to write it now
we had to go to the public library to
find this book because it's hard it is
difficult to find 40 years ago your very
first book right it's my first book and
uh it's just been reprinted in england
i'm very pleased as a new british
edition and what is it about well it's
about how the british government between
1933 and 1939
really actively tried to get on good
relations with hitler
even at the expense of small nations
or or great ideals and it has in it for
example the story of how neville
chamberlain proposed to hitler
that britain and germany should divide
africa between them should divide the
resources of africa between them
and it was this which really created my
interest in churchill
because
he seemed to be almost the only voice
opposed to that there were others but he
was
really sometimes only alone once when he
wanted the parliament to debate an
aspect of of the danger from hitler
he appealed for 50 members of parliament
to join him in the lobby out of 650 and
only two others joined him so he was
alone so that of course led me into
churchill but i wrote this fellow if i
had a pupil my very first pupil was
called richard gott and he's still alive
and uh is a good personal friend he and
i wrote the book together so first pupil
first book
and i've never co-authored a book before
but it was great fun to do it we each
took different areas and
it was 1963
and we were able to
talk to almost all the people whose
story we told in the book and not only
get their recollections which might have
been a little faulty or fudged up but
they would open their drawer open their
desk and say well i did keep a diary at
the time would you like the diary and so
on so it was my first
really understanding that oral history
doesn't only mean the memory of the
person you're talking to but the things
they've kept the things they've
collected and also their contacts and
one of the uh you know
and if you use an american phrase
goosebumps when you get pimples sure one
of the things which still gives me
goosebumps
i have a letter uh
on white house stationery and so i've
kept it in its white house envelope
written to me
two weeks after the assassination of
president kennedy from evelyn lincoln
his secretary in the white house
saying i just wanted you to know that
before the president left for dallas
he asked me to remind him to write and
thank you for your book
and that was the appeaser
it's dedicated to ajp taylor who is he
or she ajb taylor allen taylor was a he
he was a very controversial british
historian
who uh feuded fat enough constantly with
hugh trevor oprah who died the other day
and who got the professorship which
taylor craved
and taylor said to me in one of our
tutorials when i was studying with him
in 1959 1960
he said don't waste your time writing
modern history there is nothing new to
learn
and the moment he said that i thought
gilbert
go for it
rather like churchill's father saying
you're stupid and churchill spending the
rest of his life proving he wasn't
stupid so i spent the rest of my life
proving that there is more to write fort
lee new jersey you're next
yes professor i wanted to ask you uh is
it uh is it was it a protestant crusade
that was
brought about by uh england and the
united states
uh during world war ii
uh
to uh to crush
fascism and nazism
and uh and more or less neutralize the
catholic church's power
i i wouldn't say that actually
it certainly had
a christian element in it
uh it certainly had a high moral content
but actually catholics played
a considerable part for example in
britain in the war effort there was no
discrimination against catholics i mean
catholics flew as pilots alongside
prostate pilots and indeed jewish pilots
and pilots of no denomination
and one of churchill's very closest
advisors desmond morton who really was
his chief adviser on all matters
relating to intelligence and also to
governments in exile
was a catholic and quite a distinguished
catholic
san diego california
good morning i i don't know if i should
address you as sir
gilbert or or professor gilbert
uh what is the pro correct
address for you
now that you i didn't know you had been
knighted you can call me martin if you
like from san diego where i've just been
teaching for two months but it is sir
sir martin i think would be the official
part um
actually you know
you know you were talking about your
reluctance to write about stalin and
hitler because of of how evil they were
and something that i've constantly
thought is how fortunate the world was
that the two of them were matched up
against each other
at the same time
um
what how from your point of view from
your research
would russia had survived without stalin
uh as as stubborn as he was you know and
the other question i had for you what
out of uh franklin roosevelt
churchill installed what what were their
shining moments that maybe have given
you gave you goosebumps when you went
over their histories uh their shining
moments
individually
well i
on the on the russian question i think
the
there was a sort of question about
russian survival
and
what
was an alternative to hitler invading
the soviet union in 1941
was the soviet union joining the western
allies in 1939 to her to deter hitler
from aggression
and we now know from the the russian
archives
that all the efforts by the british and
french governments to draw the soviet
union in were regarded by stalin
as a deception as a trickery to embroil
him with germany and they were not they
were a desperate attempt to try to
protect these other countries from
germany
without stalin perhaps russia would have
emerged as a
essentially perhaps socialist social
democratic country
perhaps its empire wouldn't have
come into existence in the way it did
that was more sort of lenin and trotsky
than stalin creating it
uh perhaps it would have been a bit more
like today it would have been a large
country but all the french countries
would have been independent
there was an attempt which churchill
supported very strongly
to
arm and encourage the anti-bolshevik
russians in 1919 to defeat communism to
march on moscow to march on
petrograd and destroy communism as
churchill once said i tried to strangle
communism at its birth but actually
these
anti-bolshevik russian forces were very
divided
and
that project failed
there was a point at which churchill
wanted himself to go to moscow
to try to rally the bolshevik forces
uh when russia pulled out of the war
with germany in world war one and this
was disastrous for us in the west as the
germans then had all these millions of
men to throw against the allies in the
west at that point churchill said in
order to keep russia in the war fighting
on our side
i'm prepared to go to moscow join
lenin's government and in return for
them rejoining the war against germany
guaranteeing the permanence of the
bolshevik revolution so that would make
an interesting interesting novel i
suppose you asked about the inspiring
moments and that's i often think about
that and of course they do sometimes
change in in my mind
i think to my mind the most inspiring
moment for churchill and one of the
earlier questioners alluded to it in
quite an unpleasant way
was when
hitler offered to make peace with
britain after the fall of france
when hitler was already conqueror of
denmark norway france belgium holland
and hitler offered to make peace
and at one point a majority of
churchill's war cabinet
wanted to explore the peace feelers
and churchill's
ability to dissuade them from doing that
his realization that if you made any
form of compromise with hitler you would
be
among other things perpetuating the
tyranny and occupation of of
france and belgium holland norway and
denmark that was an inspiring moment it
was a day it was very toughly fought day
in the councils of the cabinet and
churchill only just prevailed and
he prevailed because he
was determined to see the thing through
and of course he couldn't go to an
election it had to be decided in a few
hours
it wasn't as if he could appeal to the
public he had to make that decision and
essentially the public then supported it
wholeheartedly rochester new york
yes sir gilbert thanks for taking my
call
i'm interested in your opinion on the
role of france and world war one they
are always
portrayed as the most innocent of the
major countries in the outbreak and
right it seems to me that
reading between the lines the
visit of their leadership to saint
petersburg just prior to russia
calling their people to arms makes one
say come on
they were doing the same thing with
russia
that germany was doing with austria and
hungary and after all they certainly had
the purse strings as well
and i'm wondering what your opinion of
that is
well it's interesting you you say that
because
curiously that was also the view
of the british of a majority of the
british cabinet at the time
and that's why they actually had decided
not to go to war
on france's behalf
if germany invaded france
because they felt that there had been
what you described that sort of
equivalence almost of provocation
and it was only when the germans went
through belgium which was part of their
strategic plan to defeat france they
they had no particular animus against
belgium as such
it was only when they went through
belgium
that the british public were outraged
and it so happened you know because
belgium was innocent in a way that
france wasn't innocent
in the sense that you're mentioning it
and uh as britain had an ancient treaty
with belgium going back i think to the
1830s
uh the public sort of demanded that the
brave belgium should be suckered and so
we sent our expeditionary force
to europe
to fight the germans really because the
germans had invaded belgium and we were
allied with france and we shared in the
retreat of the forces towards paris and
then in the reversal
uh of of the battle of the trench lines
being established and then france was
suddenly our necessary ally
but
both at the time and also by historians
after the war between the two wars what
you're saying was very much stressed
that that france had played its part in
because everybody thought that the
french thought they would be in berlin
by october the germans thought they'd be
in paris uh by september
so
none of them were thinking in terms of a
war that would go on for four years and
lead to the slaughter of millions of
soldiers
they were thinking if you like of a 19th
century rather imperialist style wall
which would be quick and victorious
denver colorado
i'd like to ask a question in regards to
the uh effect
of
uh
the distinction that uh churchill had on
the middle east with his activities in
the cairo conference in 1921
versus his view of
british and india
which seems to be somewhat in conflict
the two
areas seem to be in conflict with each
other and i'd like you to speak to that
in greater detail
oh that's that's a very difficult
question i'll try um it's just that my
brain my brain is not wrapped around it
as it might
i think that
in both cases
churchill did not like the idea
of partitioning a country and that's why
he wanted the jewish state the jewish
national home which in his view should
become a state
to
include what is now both israel and the
west bank that's to say to go from the
mediterranean to the river jordan he
didn't want a partition
of palestine between the mediterranean
and jordan between two peoples he didn't
feel among other things that
israel would be viable if it was
truncated in the way that it became
truncated in 1948
and the same i think was true of india
he he really had a sense
guided or misguided is a question of
opinion most people would think it was
misguided today he really had a sense
that the indian subcontinent india
pakistan and bangladesh were one and
that they should be unified
and that within the indian statehood the
unified statehood
the muslim minority should have full
rights and guarantees and participation
with the hindu majority
gandhi curiously supported this and it
led to a reconciliation between
churchill and gandhi towards the end of
the struggle
but nehru and also the
leader of the
muslims of muhammad ali jinnah both
wanted their own
if you like exclusive state although of
course in india there are
more muslims than in pakistan today but
they are part of the indian
republic so i think church was
consistent he didn't like the idea of
fragmentation although the scales of
these two were enormously different and
in in the case of the jews in in
palestine he believed that they should
have a
a territorial state that would which
would be large enough when the jewish
leaders accepted partition in 1937
churchill was willing to accept it
because the jewish leaders wanted it but
the leader of the jewish revisionist
vladimir jabotinsky went to see him
and persuaded him not to
agree to any partition of palestine
between the mediterranean and jordan
harrisburg pennsylvania
yes hello mr gilbert hello i greatly
appreciate your uh contribution to uh
historical work in the 20th century and
my question is
if as you had said earlier the germans
were not
collectively guilty for the holocaust
i hope i'm quoting you correctly i would
be interested to know
if there was anything particularly
distinctive about the german people or
its character
as opposed to other european nations
at that time that made it particularly
apt in carrying out the holocaust on the
scale that it did
well you you did quote me correctly i i
i don't believe there's such a thing in
collective building indeed i don't
really believe that there are such
things as national characteristics on on
the lines of uh you know some nations
are more capable of murdering than
others i think one of the things
without which the holocaust could not
have taken place and i've written about
this in my history of the holocaust and
also in my book the righteous my new
book
one of the things which
alone made it possible was the
collaboration and support of people from
many nations now the fact that there was
a latvian ss a new ukrainian ss and a
bosnian ss
and uh that the slovaks participated uh
terribly in in the deportations doesn't
mean that latvians and ukrainians and
slovaks
are and bosnians
are
collectively guilty it can often be
quite a small majority and i think the
the basic understanding is
of
and and in myatlas the holocaust i tried
to show this that
europe was under
german domination under the domination
of
a gestapo system a tyrannical system
certainly
millions of germans suffered under that
system the concentration camps initially
were filled primarily with germans the
german liberals german communists german
trade unionists
there were other victims who were
germans german homosexuals for example
german jehovah's witnesses
um so
they of course the german victims can't
be collectively
guilty for the perpetration
of crimes by other germans
collaboration made it possible in many
countries the collaboration of
a minority of people but nevertheless
collaboration of other nationalities
other groups
made it possible for this thing to
spread so widely and terrifyingly
an email from tom o'neill does the uk
have the same fascination for hitler in
the nazis as here in the usa
i think the answer sadly is is yes
um
though i believe that books about cats
sell even better than books about hitler
in britain
and your point
it's a fascination i mean i think evil
always fascinates us in in in my book
the the uh the righteous in in this new
book i i try to address the question i
also have my opinions unlike the views
of the reviewer you quoted i also
express my opinions that
for some reason
evil fascinates us
and goodness
leaves us gasping
this is a book about entirely good
people
and
it's astonishing that we should be so
surprised to find that there are these
good people
we are so in a way drilled to think of
whether it's germans as collectively
guilty or hitler is the only
figure i mean it's much harder for
someone to name
let's say a brave german who was one of
hitler's victims than to name hitler i
think of something like dietrich
bonhoeffer or pastor nemo i mean there
are many so
it always saddens me in a way that it it
could indeed surprise us more than evil
deeds
next is helena montana
go ahead helena
concerning progressive perspectives of
low ceiling variables and remedial
redundant
frequent advice programming on tv radio
how about the perspective
that the 19th century civil war and
subsequent wars could have been
prevented
with
alligator and crocodile hunts
also next lake forest illinois hello
lake forest uh yes mr gilbert i had a
question uh pertaining to something that
doesn't get doesn't seem to get a lot of
of interest and that is uh churchill's
relationship to the fall of singapore
uh it seemed to me that that was a
tremendous blow to the british empire
that really led to the the
destabilization of the
whole structure because it it pointed up
the fallibility of the british power
structure out there and uh there were
two aspects of it one
churchill seemed genuinely uh astonished
and surprised at the
weakness of the garrison and its
performance under percival uh and
appeared to be very outraged by it on
things that i've read and uh secondly
there was also some controversy some
australian friends of mine uh and others
are still very upset about the dispatch
of uh australia the uh
large number of australian troops to
singapore and also his decision to send
the i believe it was the eighth british
division uh in at the end even when they
knew it was going to fall and the the
troops never even had a chance to defend
themselves um it just was an area that
that's he seemed to have uh i'm sure he
had a lot of other things on his mind it
was about the time of the channel dash i
think and some other things but um was
that a serious blow to him and uh
and how would you how would you put that
into context well it was a serious play
i i think when you say he had other
things on his mind you know he he was
able to take and that was his strength
to deal with everything equally so it's
not as if he neglected singapore because
he had other things on his mind
uh he he was faced and the british
chiefs of staff were faced with the
following dilemma really and that is uh
and they had faced it uh earlier in
greece they'd faced it in 1941 in greece
the the enemy has essentially
overwhelming power
and
do you withdraw do you leave
or do you try to make a stand
and at what point
do you accept that your forces have to
surrender
um and
churchill wrestled with this the the
british chiefs of staff wrestled with it
and indeed the the commanders in the
field rested with it and there's no
doubt that the the japanese were able by
a series of brilliant maneuvers uh to
come down the peninsula and to approach
singapore from the land side in a way
which had not been anticipated by any
of the military planners
but the real loss i think the real the
real reason why why it was
so disastrous
was that the the japanese had secured
naval and really air mastery
and this had not been anticipated it had
not been anticipated that the united
states would lose such a vast proportion
of its fleet or that britain would lose
its two great warships the prince of
wales and the repulse so early
and in every case from japanese torpedo
bombers
so
there was really nothing he could do i
mean he
he he did try to stiffen the resolve of
the garrison as you say he was surprised
by what seemed to be general purcell's
lack of will
and once the surrender took place and it
was a massive surrender
he was very devastated because
he realized that
hitler had to be defeated in europe and
roosevelt had agreed this would be a
priority defeating hitler before
defeating hirohito
and yet you know there was going to be a
massive loss of british imperial
possessions british colonial possessions
british wealth british resources which
were essentially never recovered i mean
you're right it was the
beginning of the end or of the british
imperial
control in the far east carmel
california hello hello you're on the air
yeah uh sir martin top of the morning to
you from carmel hello with regard to
the book called the conquerors by
michael uh bachelots
have you read i'm afraid i'm ready now
well uh a great deal of that uh is about
morgenthau the secretary of the treasury
who traveled with uh with uh roosevelt
to meet churchill and to advocate it
seems from this book of the so-called
morgan thought plan about the
disposition of the ruler that is correct
yes and of course germany um my question
to you sir is uh
what can you tell us of anything about
uh how churchill may have affected by
morgenthau's presence
in the meetings
well church was very shocked by by the
morganthou plan
um
he he had
contemplated some sort of
breakup of germany but not the
de-industrialization of germany not
reducing germany to
a sort of agricultural backwater
he he did contemplate for a while
the division of german into into
possibly three separate states
um but then he quickly came to the view
particularly
when the soviet uh
troops had occupied virtually all the
capitals of central and eastern europe
and when the red army was in in control
in warsaw in prague
in belgrade in bucharest in sofia he
came to the field it was essential for a
united germany
to remain
to serve as some sort of bowl work
against communism
of course east germany was lost stalin
was already in occupation there
and that it should be restored to a
fully industrial and also democratic
society and he played quite a big part
in the attempt to fashion the the
post-war german democracy whatever
eventually emerged in the federal german
republic under adenauer
and incidentally he was very much a uh
early uh supporter of what became the
luxembourg agreements between
west germany and israel for the payment
of reparations something which here in
washington
stu eisenstadt has recently been at the
forefront has a new book out have you
read his new book yes
what do you think of it excellent
charlottesville virginia
yes hello mr gilbert um
i had a question i just i'm within 100
or so pages of finishing churchill's
history of world war ii
and i'm inspired by his continual
references to the english-speaking
peoples of the world sort of talking
about the common cultural political
creeds of the english-speaking people of
the world especially you know the
british and the americans right
this is something i recently had the
privilege of visiting britain and this
is something i think that still exists
to a great degree on an official level
certainly between bush and blair but
between the peoples of britain america i
don't know if it really does or if it
ever did did churchill's having an
american mother
effect to any degree sort of his his
world view and and seeing the
commonalities between the american and
the british that may have helped him to
a degree win roosevelt support and pros
successfully prosecute the war
yes i think his having an american
mother was very important he visited
america for the first time when he was
21 he had a tremendous admiration for
the united states
uh he loved the boisterousness of
america he loved what he called the
crude young people of america he also
had a tremendous understanding and
respect of american industrial power and
then in world war one of of american
military power he begged the british
government not to launch the terrible
offensives
uh culminating in passchendaele and the
slaughter of allied troops at pashadel
he begged them not to launch those
offenses until the americans were in the
war and then american power would mean
that you wouldn't have those terrible
trench stalemates and attritions
he he believed in anglo-american
relations he fought all his life against
the many britons who are cynical and
skeptical about the united states uh
curiously tony blair is having to fight
against that today
when churchill retired finally from
government and prime minister in 1955 he
called his cabinet together
and he said there are only two things i
want to tell you before i go
man is spirit
which incidentally may be interesting to
the man who asked about churchill's view
of god man is spirit and
never be separated from the americans
and he believed that and he had fought
for that really throughout his political
career and during world war ii
roosevelt understood that
churchill understood britain's
tremendous weakness vis-a-vis the united
states
and
was enormously relieved when roosevelt
clearly understood that britain could
not survive without massive american aid
which roosevelt gave often in virtual
breach of the neutrality agreements uh
tremendous help which he gave above and
below below the table
so churchill's pro-americanism was both
an understanding of that that only
america could really protect the
democracies when all said and done
and also that he had this great faith
and belief in america even after the the
uh
crash the great crash when he lost a lot
of his money had a lot of american
stocks he was one of the very first to
to reinvest in american stocks he said
american wealth cannot be destroyed they
carved it out of the fields and prairies
and forests and it'll always be there
would emit would history
history being what it was would our
relationship between the two countries
today be the same with that churchill
he certainly played a a major part in in
in his day in in maintaining it and also
of course in in the whole debate in
britain about europe and the european
union he posited this this concept
of the three circles
uh britain
the commonwealth
and the united states and he said these
circles always have to overlap we can't
we can't separate ourselves in the
united states and be really a power
britain in europe britain and the
commonwealth and britain and the united
states you mentioned about his
retirement he went to chartwell at the
end
he did well first of all he went to
sicily to paint and he wrote a wonderful
edge to the queen which i quote in my
churchill life
saying how how marvelous it was to have
responsibility suddenly taken off your
shoulders there's this picture you also
have although this is is is in the
garden in france this this photo
uh how old might he have been oh he was
in his late 80s then he he loved the
south of france he always went there to
to paint and to sit and to
he loved painting of course he painted
he loved colors he loved getting away
from the focus
of problems by focusing on the canvas
that was his relief
do those paintings still exist oh yes
they're everywhere the uh i once went i
know any of our callers are from uh
kansas city if we've had any but he once
went i once went to kansas city and saw
the largest collection of churchill's
paintings western mississippi and there
were four and they all belonged to jesse
hall of hallmark who was still alive he
showed them to him but no no he he
painted hundreds of canvases and he
often gave them to his friends
and
when he was painting in marrakesh i
think
this uh of course then he died two years
after for instance the assassination of
jfk which may surprise some people did
he talk about any of these things i mean
we there was a space program already
underway by the time of this year and
what he talked about he he was aware of
all these things he was worried about a
proliferation of atomic power i mean
it's interesting now because we're
talking about weapons of mass
destruction by which we mean among
others nuclear weapons and he was very
worried about the uh
he he tried to work out some way which
he thought could be done through
uh
soviet american british summits he
invented the word summit he was the one
who coined the word summit for what we
now call summits that there had to be
the these
three powers had to get together and and
basically washington and moscow had to
find common ground or there would be
nuclear disaster and and one of the
questions asked about bombing and these
terrible
uh bombings in the second world war of
course britain was bombed uh
initially massively by the germans
before we dropped a single bomb on
germany but the
he once said to a friend who said you
know looking back over the
20th century you know is there anything
you you wish hadn't happened
and he said yes i wish man had never
learned to fly
next call oakland california
yes
just quickly thank you so much for
c-span and
i don't know what we would do without
men like uh uh mr gilbert or sir robert
sir martin gilbert excuse me
um
thank you so much for your good work and
the uh uh winston churchill's uh
world war ii
um
he's i can't remember if it was yalta
he's having a discussion with stalin
and he asked stalin about the problems
in the ukraine leading up to world war
ii and almost no one ever writes about
this
that uh
churchill is so crafty
he puts the question to him in a very
very
uh diplomatic way what about your
problems in the ukraine i understand
you're having problems there stalin
apparently had several drinks says
oh it was a great difficult time
they fought back and
we you know i think he said it was 10
million that they had to the exact word
was liquidate
and this was prior to world war ii and
it went right up into
[Music]
the opening of the war
do you have any more information on that
because that was just
an incredible piece of information that
i almost never hear anyone mention
anything about when we hear about the
jewish holocaust but not the slaughter
that went on even before world war ii
thank you so much for your great work
thank you well church was was he was
interested in ukraine
um he had he had been involved initially
in that very short-lived
period of ukrainian independence after
world war one
and he was then british secretary of
state for war
and and he believed that there should be
could be a an independent ukraine which
would be viable
and so after the uh
re-annexational conquest of of ukraine
by the soviets i mean moving in where
the tsars had been earlier
um he he followed what was happening in
ukraine of course a lot of it was
shrouded in darkness
and it's taken brilliant historians like
robert conquest of stanford university
to to reveal even to the russians the
extent of what happened but he did
follow it and he was very concerned in
the 1930s
um by the starvation and the trials in
ukraine
and
that's why he raised the question as you
say rather craftedly
with stalin
stalin instantly played the ukrainian
card
rather deviously back to churchill
when churchill was trying to secure for
the polls an eastern frontier running
where it does today along the river back
the current eastern frontier between
poland and russia
when church was trying to secure that
stalin suddenly produced an unknown
figure
at the conference table nikita
khrushchev
and he said khrushchev here will tell
you about the large ukrainian population
in what you claim is poland so that's
you know stalin trying to push
the russian border even deeper into
poland than he did
atlanta
uh mr gilbert um i have a question about
um sir winston's son randolph
in your book in search of churchill
there's a chapter entitled uh the beast
of burkhold right
um
which uh deals with sir winston's son
randolph and your work for him right and
i was just wondering uh what is your
opinion of him as an employer
as a person and as a journalist in his
story and and finally
do you think the burden of being the son
of a famous father was perhaps
greater on him
[Music]
than on
other persons
first of all i ought to explain why i
called the chapter beast of bergholt i
think i explained it in the chapter
randolph lived at a house
in a village called east berghold a
rather nice suffolk village
and in those days when telegrams were a
frequent method of communication he
received one day a telegram addressed to
randolph churchill beast bergholt the
telegraphic listener put a b in and it's
so amused him that henceforth he called
himself the beast
of berghold he was a wonderful employer
i once when he was paying me the sum of
850 pounds sterling a year which was
very handsome wage
uh i got down to breakfast and there was
a letter from him he'd stayed in bed and
it said dear martin i've been looking at
my salary book and i see you are
scandalously underpaid
and he raised me to 12.50 well i don't
think many employers write to their
employees and say you're scandalously
underpaid and then rectified but you
also talk a lot in this book about you
had a lot of qualms before taking this
job yeah and a lot of qualms while doing
the job but
he was a good historian he loved history
he didn't really have the patience to do
it uh even when i joined him in 1962 he
wasn't very well
he was also easily distracted he did all
sorts of other books he wrote a book
about the 1963
british political crisis where all we
assistants
had to help him he wrote a book about
the 1967 war in israel he embarked on
the biography of j f kennedy which
robert and jacqueline kennedy asked him
to do which i mentioned earlier
but he he loved history and he he had no
qualms himself about
about publishing negative things about
his father he didn't want it to be a
whitewash and your last question which
is you know in a way the most
important and difficult to answer about
whether he was overshadowed by his
father
actually he and his father got on
extremely well they often quarreled but
they had an intimacy which i've not seen
and i've known some political figures
and their children i've not seen
in in other political figures and their
sons he
churchill loved randolph randolph loved
and admired his father
he fought all his battles i think the
key is that that randolph could always
be relied upon if church was in trouble
as he was so often say in the 30s
randolph would fight his battles and
during world war ii randolph was an
amazing help to churchill in letting him
know what was really going on because
you know prime minister like the
president doesn't always get the truth
from his subordinates and he was a son
so devoted to his father that he really
uh made positive and good contributions
and whenever they met they embraced and
they loved each other and then they
quarreled and shouted and then they
embraced again what about churchill's um
own
protection of his image
in his image not only of the day but his
image for history was he protective of
it
he was concerned very concerned about it
and a lot of his writing was to try to
as he saw it set the record straight and
repair his image because he had a very
battered image his image in britain is
much more better than in the united
states so he was concerned about it and
uh but when when he was going to go off
himself to gallipoli and uh he thought
he was going to be killed in in 1915 he
he wrote a letter which was to be opened
in the event of his death at gallipoli
so it was never opened uh and i opened
it in in with uh lady churchill at my
side with her permission in 1969
and in it he he makes various wonderful
dispositions for her and so on and then
he says i want you to get hold of all my
historical documents and record
one day the truth will be told
randolph will carry the lamp
so he did have faith that a historical
documents would be to his credit and be
that his son would as he indeed started
to do write his biography he was out of
office by the time television was really
getting going
did he well he did he have a feel about
tv
he was he he made a number of important
television broadcasts before the 1950
and 51 elections and it was good he
liked he liked it he loved it he loved
anything where he was
communicating with the public he was
good at knock about stuff and he was
good at serious stuff la jolla
california
mr martin
earlier you commented on william
manchester and his work on churchill i
was wondering whether you could comment
about the perspectives of john lucas
and of lord jenkins who've written a
great deal about churchill as well and
could you tell me whether it's still
possible to obtain your eight volume
work i very much enjoyed reading the one
volume
uh long synopsis but i would love to get
the original work well if you're phoning
from la jolla you can go to dc will's
bookshop at the corner of perlin gerrard
and i'm sure dennis wills who's one of
the most remarkable booksellers in
america will help you uh as to
commenting on the other historians i'd
rather not because i've i've written my
work i would like you to read my work
i have a great healthy respect for
everybody else's work but
as far as churchill's concerned i do
believe i've i've got as close to the
man as it's possible to get
in in your book in search of churchill
there's this photo i thought was
interesting it's winston churchill here
it looks like it's on a boat someplace
is that and that's randolph's son is
that correct
and this is
i don't know this is
right what was the connection between
winston churchill and eric when
churchill retired in in 1955 he spent a
lot of time in the south of france
and uh one day onassis came
to lunch
where he was staying and invited him on
the yacht
and onassis was wonderful actually i i
he was very kind to me when randolph
died he was very sympathetic person and
he basically said to churchill come on
my yacht and i'll protect you from
prying eyes you know you can go where
you want to go you can relax you know
the paparazzi won't disturb you uh he
was a genuine gentle host and of course
there was an added bonus that often
maria callous was on board so if you
wanted a little bit of singing and
churchill loves singing you could
certainly have maria kalas entertain you
warwick rhode island
hello
thank you dr gilbert thank you cs band i
have a question regarding a churchill
relationship with the ajax program
uh between british and american for
overthrowing uh
elected democratic elected government of
dr mussadek in iran
and the question sir
uh
what was he thinking dr
churchill how was
his contribution and his idea about that
coup in iran
well i think you know you have to look
at it in its historical context in
1914 before the outbreak of world war
one
churchill had purchased on behalf of
britain 51 of the anglo-persian oil
company
and on the basis of that not only was
britain's whole
naval fleet
able to
maintain itself during two world wars
but also on the profits of the
anglo-persian oil company
britain was able on those profits alone
which churchill had secured in 1914 was
able to pay for every single warship
built between 1914 and 1939 so here was
an acquisition a
legitimate acquisition
which uh dr masadek
decided to to nationalize to take away
and i think it would have been
an appalling dereliction of churchill's
national duty
if he had simply shrugged his shoulders
just as a few years later anthony eden
felt that he could not shrug his
shoulders when
colonel nasa the egyptian ruler
nationalized the stewies canal which
also had been legitimately
bought and worked by a consortium of
nations including britain and france
you've had several emails about this
question i'll just grab one of them from
a mr sempa what is your view based on
your research of the catholic churches
and the vatican's approach toward the
holocaust during the second world war
was popeye pius a courageous outspoken
opponent of the holocaust or a passive
witness to it or somewhere in between
well again i please read my new book the
righteous i've written extensively there
about the catholic church
some of whose leaders played a
remarkable part in the rescue of jews
many of whose priests and many ordinary
catholics played a remarkable part the
pope himself was was denounced by dr
goebbels
uh for having taken the sight of the
jews
in his christmas message in december
1942 where he criticized racism
the pope also played a part which i
describe in some detail
in
the rescue of three quarters of the jews
of rome at very short notice when the ss
came in and tried to round up all five
thousand and at least four thousand were
given shelter in the vatican itself and
other catholic places so
i think again my book is i hope a book
which
can restore in a way on the foundation's
historical fact
the true and wonderful achievements of
catholics in helping jews during the war
this book has been published by henry
holt last call washington dc
hello
you're on the air sir go ahead with your
question yes uh give me your extensive
background in 20th century history i
wonder if you would exp speculate on the
significance of north korea's current
nuclear program and i wonder if you'd
liken this development to any of the
steps of rear armament uh by the fascist
powers in the 30s
i think the the problem in the 1930s was
that it was impossible to get a
any form of collective
organization either under the league of
nations or by a consortium of of of
threatened powers
against
realmen
today we have the united nations we have
a much more active
[Music]
attempt by the united nations to prevent
nuclear proliferation
uh it's ironic that it should be korea
because of course the last united
nations war was a war against
uh north korea when they attacked south
korea so one hopes that the
international community has the power
and more importantly the will to prevent
this uh proliferation from becoming a
danger martin gilbert we are out of time
three hours went very fast let's just
review for for our viewers some of your
books so that they can if they want to
take a look the history of the 20th
century what will they find in this
they will find in the single volume
the whole story globally right so
america has its part
from 1900 to 1999
and your 1991 combined biography there i
hope they'll find
so many fascinating aspects of churchill
that they will become churchill experts
themselves and then you had mentioned
earlier that this one was one of your
personal favorites yes if they read
first world war again they'll find it
it's comprehensive it deals with all
fronts all nations the united states
and its heroes and its contribution
are as important in that book as those
of any country and you have also one for
the second world war and the second
world war also it brings together the
war of armies and navies and fleets and
the war of civilians and the holocaust
and it also tells the story of how
america really saved the western world
your series of atlases
if you want to know about moving
frontiers and
what countries get up to uh it's all
there it's in map form it's very simple
they're black and white maps
and you can see who attacked whom
who conquered whom
and a lot too about domestic activities
and uh changes of government and social
policy i don't know if i'm missing a big
one here that
let's take just you again once again
your newest book that's the newest one
and that's that's
a story of goodness it's a story about
good people it's a story about
christians and a few muslims
incidentally who risk their own lives
again and again and again to try to save
jewish life it's the story of some 20
000 known
people and many others whose names
aren't known who did the right thing at
a time when evil was in the ascendant
and your plan for your future books
keep writing
but you have your churchill books
i have to finish the remaining five
churchill document volumes those for
those i need funding but uh basically uh
that's a project and then hillsdale
college michigan i hope will reissue the
whole church of biography all eight
volumes and all 15 volumes of documents
and if people can't find them they can
find them in their library if they can't
find the eight volumes they can find
them in the library or now of course on
the internet through eight books or one
of these
vehicles for secondhand books you can
get everything sir martin gilbert thank
you very much for spending three hours
with our viewers appreciate it thank you
in depth with martin gilbert thanks for
joining us
you've been watching in depth with
martin gilbert if you missed any portion
of the three-hour interview you can see
this program again at 5 pm eastern and
tonight at midnight eastern
next month on in depth susan sante